I love my morning routine so much I call
it the million dollar morning because it
is in fact the morning routine that
makes me feel like a million bucks it
gives me laser focus it helps me make
progress and it is the structure and
Foundation upon which I chip away at my
goals and I stay consistent and I have
built the business and continue to build
the business that I have built that life
that you envision you're capable of
achieving it you can do the work to make
that version of yourself a reality but
it's not going to happen out of thin air
you gotta put in the work and I
personally believe that that work begins
first thing in the morning that every
single morning you can wake up and
experience a clean sleep you can wake up
and you can create a morning routine not
that the you right now likes but the
morning routine that the future you
needs and the bottom line is whether you
consider yourself to be a morning person
or not a morning route teen is essential
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that actually a bit of
belief and I still need their stories
today and I'm honored to share them with
you here as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation for the one and
only Mel Robbins enjoy
a morning routine is like the first
Domino
let's just agree that every single day
of your life you wake up and you have
the opportunity to create a new
experience in your life
and that first series of decisions that
you make
which are basically your morning routine
it's like the beginning Domino that
falls
and if your morning routine sucks like
my morning routine used to suck the
first Domino that falls in your day is
procrastination stress anxiety
depression suckiness and that tends to
trigger a whole lot more of that
now let's talk about the other option
have you ever had a morning where you
rolled out of bed because you had to be
somewhere
you actually met a friend at the gym
and the exercise class
was not only not that bad it was kind of
fun
and you felt really energized and proud
of yourself for going
and you were set up for the meeting that
you had you were prepared what's it like
when that Domino Falls it feels good
doesn't it it makes you feel confident
and alive and proud of yourself it kind
of creates this energy and this Motion
in your life
and that brings me to a simple statement
the solution to almost all the problems
in your life
is your morning routine
if you were to get serious
about creating a morning routine that
makes you feel like a million bucks that
sets you up with the structure and
momentum and Positive Choices that act
like a domino that send you into your
day feeling like you have started the
day off with a bang check in the right
boxes getting it done feeling proud
putting yourself first
imagine how the rest of your day flows
you see how you set your day up is how
it ends up say it again
how you set your day up is how it ends
up
and if you are serious about making more
money or making change stick or getting
things done or just feeling happier or
finally learning how to put yourself on
the list let's get laser focused on your
morning routine
because when you get laser focused on
your morning routine and setting
yourself up for Success from the get-go
it's pretty amazing What flows from
there confidence is not a Feeling
confidence is embodied in action
my definition of confidence is
confidence is the willingness to try
I'm going to say it again
your new definition of confidence
embodied by the research
confidence is the willingness to try
confidence is an action that's what it
is and this phenomenon has been heavily
researched by social psychologists and
there's even a term for confidence being
an action see there's this positive
feedback loop that happens when you're
willing to try something before you feel
ready when you're willing to step into
that leadership role and put yourself
out there and take risks and make
mistakes and shove that self-doubt to
the side when you're willing to try
Neuroscience research says that you
create something called a confidence
competence Loop and let me explain this
to you because there's a lot of common
sense here right every single time you
try something new
you're either going to be really good at
it or you're going to be terrible at it
right
but you always learn something
but you have to try you might be really
good at it when you start trying to set
them you might be really miserable at it
but here's the thing if you try
something for the first time
you're either going to fail or succeed
but you always learn something and
that's where this confidence competence
Loop and the Neuroscience research comes
in because even when you try
when you learn a little something you
gain a little competency right because
of everything that you learned the first
time around
it gets a little bit easier it gets a
little bit better but it all begins with
being willing to try no matter where
you're starting from because if you are
the kind of person that's always willing
to try you will always grow and you will
always learn and the more that you try
and the more that you learn the less you
doubt yourself the less resistance that
you have and bada bang bada boom all of
a sudden you feel confident in this new
role all of a sudden you feel confident
doing a backflip off a boat because you
tried a thousand times and you belly
flopped and you embarrassed yourself and
you got a wedgie and then what do you
know because you were willing to keep
trying all of that competency that got
gained of trying over and over and over
and over again it's how you gained
mastery
see feeling confident
is kind of
um it's it's almost like the wrong way
to say it because that's what you feel
after you've done it over and over and
over again but true confidence Begins
the moment you're willing to try Sarah's
question was this are there ways to
unlock sudden rapid steps to big change
in a short period of time or is this a
dangerous misconception
now I said yes
there is a way for you to experience big
change in a short period of time
if you change how you view yourself
I mean that's the biggest kind of change
that you can experience
when you change your identity when you
change what you believe is possible
that's transformational
now one other thing that Sarah said
though is she asked is it a dangerous
misconception
to think that big change happens
immediately
and that brings me to the topic of
habits
see change doesn't happen overnight
but when you understand the science of
habits what you realize is that change
little change it compounds daily
and the massive change that you
experience in a short period of time
when you focus on habit formation is how
you relate to yourself so I'm going to
give you an example let's say that you
set a goal that this is the year that
you are going to run your first marathon
you're going to train for it you're
going to finish the race
now it will take time it's going to take
you time to achieve that goal
but if you make it a habit to wake up
every day and get out the door and go
for that training run within a matter of
days
something kind of crazy happens
you experience this massive change
because you start to see yourself
differently
you start to see yourself as a runner
now have you achieved that goal yet no
that's going to take time
but the power of habits is that as you
practice them they start to change your
identity they become evidence that
you're the kind of person that goes for
a run so in the beginning habits are
just something that you and I do but
over it but over time
habits change who you are I think you
should Chase what energizes you everyone
talks about passion Legacy purpose
the one word to pay attention to is
energy I love that that's it let's
simplify this okay so
whatever
energizes you naturally expands you
feels like possibility is exciting to do
it may be scary that doesn't matter it
has to do with how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good it expanded you it
energized you chasing the money that was
the game that was your passion that was
your there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are watching because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what ha
and and the reason why I say that is
because people talk about the word
passion yeah or purpose right
and the truth is it's not a person place
or a thing it's not
it is
the feeling of being expanded and
energized right if you're pursuing your
passion it means that you wake up every
day and are energized so instead of
trying to think what's my purpose what's
my passion what's my purpose what's my
passion
yeah instead of thinking like that I
want you instead to ask yourself what's
what could I do today that would
energize me what energizes me if it's
making money
figure out how to make money right if it
is making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's [__] thrilling yeah but
what happens is once you learn how to do
something once you can do it over and
over again and so it starts to become
routine yeah which means it's no longer
energizing right which is why every
entrepreneur out there goes through the
mode of chasing the money and then you
hit the money that you need to make then
you're like I'm not fulfilled I don't
know what to do yeah
you know I did that everybody does yeah
and it's because you were energized by
the money and now you're not yeah now
you got to be energized by the next
thing yeah and for you it's clearly
service it's clearly making a difference
it's empowering others and so when I
look back on my trajectory yeah the
thing that energizes me
is making people
feel like they matter
yeah
it's that simple it is giving people
hope
in a situation where they don't have it
it is shining a light on the path
forward when somebody feels stuck in
darkness also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there why
are habits awesome I'll tell you why
habits are awesome because when a
behavior becomes automatic there's zero
drama in your life it's just so much
easier like I'll give you my husband the
man is Mr habit he just rolls out of bed
like nothing's happened he gets up he
gets dressed he meditates he goes to the
gym he walks the dog he journals he does
it automatically
no drama
there are certainly areas in my life
where I would love to be less dramatic
less emotional less resistant to the
things that I want to do I'd love to
just sort of roll through it like my
husband does
and so lets you and I
let's not just make this like a
conversation let's move from listening
to doing
if I could take a science-back magic
wand
and I could remove all the resistance
that you feel in your body
what is one Behavior change that you
would like to make
one new habit or you know sometimes it's
easier to say what's a bad habit you'd
like to break get you your nails
do you
hit the snooze button five times
said in the positive what's a new habit
you'd like to create
would you like to
exercise every day
do you want to get your finances in
order and be more responsible with money
I'm going to give you a few examples
okay
would you love to be the kind of person
we're part of your routine is to get
outside and exercise every day
or how about the kind of person who
keeps your room or your desk clean or
you have a zero inbox that'd be pretty
awesome
would you like to be the kind of person
that gets up 30 minutes earlier than you
do right now just rolls right out of bed
like my husband does
or how about the kind of person who
feels comfortable in Social settings
you push yourself out there a little bit
more
you uh you know push through that
discomfort you feel a little bit more
outgoing
maybe you want to make it a habit to
meditate and feel like you're the kind
of person that's more mindful
that's where the science of habits is so
important why do habits matter so much
I'll tell you why habits matter
you've learned one reason and that has
to do with identity right but the real
reason why habits matter
is because learning new habits are the
only way to go from what your day-to-day
life looks like right now
to something different
it's the only way
it's the bricks on the pathway to
changing your life that's what habits
are
and habits are evidence every time that
you get out that door and you go for the
run it's evidence that you are becoming
a particular type of person
the other reason why habits are so
important habits are so important
it's because they make your life easier
I mean I want you to just stop and
consider something think about how hard
it is
to be the kind of person who has a habit
of hitting the snooze button four or
five times every morning
and then you drag yourself out of bed
that's a habit and you start your day
chronically late that's a habit I used
to do this I used to do this this was
the Mel Robbins that you did not know I
was a chronic snooze button hitter I
would drag myself out of bed by the time
I got out of bed the kids had missed the
bus I started the day behind it was a
nightmare it was so hard to have that
bad habit and in order to change I
needed to become a different person
I needed to become a person that got up
when the alarm rang that had a morning
routine and that organized my morning so
that I would begin the day with a sense
of accomplishment that's what I wanted
instead of beginning the day like I was
behind and I was already failing before
I got out of bed and the gateway to
making that change is changing your
habits in the morning
when you have habits that support you
and your goals and the kind of person
you want to become your life gets easier
and that's why habits truly matter this
is where I think people go off the rails
they they're sitting at home thinking
yeah I want to start a podcast as well
and I want to hear because I know that
you end up doing it on a way more
professional stage but walk people
through what who'd you call was it a
relationship that you built 20 years ago
I want people to follow that yeah so
first things first
I went to my friend Google and I'm like
how do you start a podcast honest to God
because
I'm smart enough to know it's different
than radio
and I didn't even know what equipment
people have I didn't know anything about
okay do you go to like how do you put a
podcast up
do you put it everywhere I don't know
like is there a form that you put the
title on and the captions and then do
you send it somewhere like I know how to
upload a video to YouTube
I know how to but I don't know anything
about this market and so I went to
Google
um You're gonna laugh at me but I bought
a course about podcasting not laughing
at all
um I uh studied a bunch of videos about
the type of equipment that people bought
um I then just started stalking people
that are doing it and I started to say
my myself okay
what does somebody that already has a
podcast what do they do that I'm not
currently doing and so the first step is
obviously learn about it identify a
group of people that serve as what I
call your lights on the path and so
lights on the path are people that are
anywhere from one step ahead of you
to 10 years ahead of you and these are
all people that can guide you forward if
you study what they did and most of them
by the way we live in the most magical
period of time you have no excuse
for not walking toward what you want I
realize it may be harder for some of us
with mental health issues I realize that
not everybody starts at the same
starting line because of bias and all
kinds of things that can happen to
people but the bottom line is through
your actions and attitude you can create
anything you want
and look I'm sitting here saying I've
been wanting to do a podcast for eight
years and for six years I was nothing
but excuses for why I couldn't get
started and then finally I'm like I
gotta start
and so you start by Google the topic
number one become a student of what you
want to be first
that's the mindset what can I learn
what are people doing that is
calling to me what are people doing that
I don't like and so as I started being a
student of this really important that's
why I say Google Google is a search
engine become a student of what you want
to learn about or launch in your life
and there's a bazillion books there's
master classes there's free videos
there's workshops and what's so cool
people like Tom are unpacking this for
you with people and so you can also hear
people's Stories the question is how do
you deal with the anxiety that comes
from waking up and being on a roll and
realizing that when you're making things
happen it's easy to look back and
realize how much of your life you wasted
and that makes you present to how
potentially little time you have left
and how much there is to do in the
little time that you have I can so
relate to this so really relate to this
the the few things I want to say about
this is that I don't think that our
experience of feeling anxiety about
getting it all done before your life is
over getting it all done in the time
that you have I don't think it's Unique
I think that that is something that
starts to happen when you feel like your
life is on a roll and you're not present
to misery but you're actually present to
power and joy and all the cool possible
things that you could do does the
anxiety or how do you make the anxiety
go away I don't think you can I think
that that is a very normal thing to feel
when you're a big thinker and you become
present to the fact that when you put in
the work and when you focus you really
are capable of creating just about
whatever you want in your life and
that's both empowering and daunting and
terrifying as hell and so you can't get
away from that anxiety but you can
respond to the trigger I often and feel
what you're talking about when I'm on an
airplane and maybe it's because I really
I feel very vulnerable and out of
control when I get on a plane and I
click the Buckle and I realize this
puppy could go down and then I think
about okay I spent 49 years here there's
so much more I wanted to do so I can
relate to this so there's two things to
this one is being present to time
passing and the fact that we're all
going to die and that your life is a
[__] gift when you get present to
that that's the biggest motivator on the
planet and when you feel one of those
moments what I do is I shrink it down
and I try to find something in this
moment that I'm incredibly grateful for
so that if it were to end right now then
all would be well I think about the
sunset I'm looking at I find a picture
of my kids and my husband I think about
you know the lives that have been
touched by the five second rule and that
gratitude food in the moment allows my
mind to not go psycho thinking about the
big vastness around life in those big
topics so that calms me down immediately
that's number one number two I think a
slightly different question than
um it's probably anxiety but I think it
has more to do with momentum and how
when you start to get unstuck and you
start to see things happening you'll
notice
that things feel like they start moving
faster as if you are on a treadmill and
somebody has secretly come up and turned
it up on you and there are days where
we're moving through our day like this
morning was one of them we're getting
ready for this live training and all of
a sudden I caught myself almost about
ready to hyperventilate because I wasn't
present to this I was present to what
happens when we have a thousand people
show up and where are we gonna hold
you know you kind of speed it up on
yourself
so when that happens I know that I'm in
the future
54321 I need to be right here and right
now and that when you start having big
things happen and when you start feeling
unstuck and when things start moving the
momentum you know because an object in
motion tends to stay in motion your
anxiety will make it roll faster that
will not make you effective you have to
slow it down immediately just in the
case of getting overwhelmed by the big
themes in life when you start to feel
like things are going too fast oh my God
oh my God I don't have a time no yes you
do
slow it down
okay you know I'm always looking for new
ways to explain the power of the five
second rule and the power of five second
decisions and I read something that Tim
Ferriss said that really resonated with
me and he had this one line buried in a
podcast somewhere that just jumped out
and it's it's it's stuck and what he
said is he said something about how
there's a gap between the world and the
things that trigger you and your
response and your entire life is that
Gap when you start to this is not what
he said he I kind of identified this Gap
and I of course intrinsically was like
well absolutely that's the five second
window between instinct or stimulus and
your reaction and when you start to
understand that your whole life plays
out in this five second Gap and that
there's a gap that's five seconds long
between fear and courage and there's a
gap that's five seconds long between
self left out and confidence that is
your life and what's super cool about
understanding that your whole life is
inside this Gap is it's so small
everybody that you have the ability to
control it life's always gonna throw
triggers at you and there will always be
all kinds of cool things that inspire
you your wisdom and you get to choose
what happens in that Gap do you succumb
to an excuse or do you push yourself
forward when you start to speak up in
business you'll be shocked at how you
start to speak up and your relationships
when you start to make hard phone calls
whether it's in a selling situation
you'll be surprised at how you'll start
to close the gap and have hard
conversations in your personal life and
so that Gap is everywhere and it's the
same everywhere and when you start to go
to work in controlling how you live in
that gap between stimulus or idea and
your response that's where the magic is
and that's what you're experiencing
close your eyes
and think about the next year of your
life
what do you want the next year of your
life to look like
Begin by making a wish
that's how I began two years ago
yup my business was upside down kids
were in shambles my husband was
struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything
I had to create a break from that moment
of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time
I had no idea what the new chapter of my
life would be or could be here's what I
did know I want to stay in this one and
that's all you need to know
all you need to know is you don't want
to stay in the place that you're in
right now
that right there is a wish for something
better if you know what you don't want
it's very easy to change as soon as you
start removing or letting go of things
that aren't working you'll see all new
possibilities no matter how you feel
start taking the actions that align with
what you want in your life stop making
the mistake of waiting to feel happy or
motivated before you take action the
secret it's taking action first because
if you can get moving you can keep
moving and research shows that just a
little boost in your mood impacts your
productivity for the rest of the day it
impacts your focus it gives you a little
uptick in energy taking actions that
align with the bigger vision and the
future you it Taps into this huge body
of research called behavioral activation
therapy now you're going to learn a
tremendous amount about this therapy
modality in future episodes of the Mel
Robbins podcast but here's how I'd
summarize it for you act like the person
you want to become in the future no
matter how you feel in the present
moment look I know it sounds simple act
like the future you but this is grounded
in decades of research and it works this
is how I've made every single change in
my life once I figure out what I want to
do or the kind of person I want to
become I figure out someone else in the
world that's doing it and I just reverse
engineer it and that's how you create a
brick path that leads from where you are
right now to where that wish of yours
wants to take you and every morning wake
up take one action in the lines with
what you want or the person that you
want to become and you can consider that
action it represents one brick
and if you keep doing that day by day
Brick by Brick action by action you're
going to look up a year from now and
you'll realize oh my God I just paved a
brick path leading to my dreams you are
in control
of the one thing that everybody cares
about that everybody complains about and
everybody's trying to steal from you and
that is your time and in fact if you're
worried about not having enough time let
me tell you something that I know about
you you're not using your time
effectively you're not being deliberate
about how you're spending your time and
the problem isn't time and whether or
not you have enough of it the problem is
you're not being completely selfish
deliberate and
just in control of how you're spending
it you're letting other people distract
you you're letting your negative beliefs
distract you and so that's gotta stop
today because here's the truth whether
you're 70
or you're 77. you have plenty of time to
start working toward the things that you
care about one of the things that I wear
right now is my little my intent
bracelet this little thing and my word
for the year is deliberate
and when it comes to time you have to be
deliberate because you have plenty of
time it's a matter of whether or not
you're being deliberate about how you're
using it and that's the thing that you
have to stop you got to stop giving your
time away you got to stop wasting your
time with people you don't care about
you got to stop wasting time listening
to this the excuses from the past they
don't apply you can make anything happen
if you just start putting in the work
and that's going to require you to get
deliberate about making the time to do
the work and you can do the work that
you need to do to change your life 10
minutes a day that's it start working 10
minutes a day start taking an online
course start investigating going back to
school start following people that
inspire you around launching your own
business you have time so stop with the
habit of telling yourself you don't the
only advice that's going to work is vice
is advice that you Flex to work in your
life
and so one of the reasons why I'm
constantly sharing these really simple
things to do is because that's the only
things that I can fit into my life my
life is very complicated just like yours
and so I can't fit in two hours of
exercise
but I can fit in 15 minutes
I can't fit in training for a marathon
right now but I can get a walk in three
days a week
and so what you're gonna find is that if
you hold yourself to an impossible
standard you're going to feel like that
standard is impossible
if you become not only realistic about
the demands of your life
but you also become very rigorous about
what you demand of yourself in terms of
you know I'm not going to force myself
to some ridiculous standard I got two
toddlers I'm a single parent it's not
safe for me to walk alone outside and
leave them I just can't do it so what
can I do
and so
when you say so that's so that's just
hopefully getting rid of like the
the kind of
comparison thing because I do it too you
know I often have this conversation with
Christine who's our chief operating
officer of 143 Studios which is our
production company and she's also my
sister-in-law and I love her because I'm
like the flighty creative ball dropper
genius type person right I call myself a
genius like ingest but I'm creatively
fruity all over the place just flying
high she is a CFO Excel spreadsheet get
everything in the columns kind of lady
Mel says yes Christine says no that's
basically the joke inside the company
Mel said yes but Christine said no so
anyway I was complaining to her the
other day because
um of course like you I bash myself when
I see other people out achieving me
because I've got to win some imaginary
competition here in life and I see a
friend of mine who is going on a book
tour
and he is going on a book tour that is
lasting three months
and I turned to Christine I'm like this
is unbelievable it's so cool
and she turned me and she goes
he doesn't have children
you can't be on the road that long Mel
it's not gonna work for you
and I'm like oh
that's right she's like you got to stop
comparing yourself to people whose lives
don't look like yours
you will never be able to achieve what
somebody who is a single male can
achieve because you've got other demands
on your time right now you will never be
able to achieve what a 23 year old can
do right now because you've got aging
parents and three kids and a business to
run
and so please please stop making
yourself feel like
because you are looking at somebody who
has totally different life circumstances
than you and by the way this does not
mean that there's something wrong with a
23 year old Fitness influencer I think
that's freaking fantastic that
somebody's doing that with their life
there's nothing wrong with somebody who
is going on a book tour for three months
I think that's fantastic and there's
clearly a part of me that wants to do
more of that but at the moment
I gotta face reality and the reality is
based on my values based on what life
looks like right now
I'm not going to do that but what I can
do is figure out what advice I respond
to what changes I want to make and then
I can fit that into my life every single
day when you wake up you can decide who
you're going to be and the reason why
it's so important to wake up and either
consciously choose decide or set an
intention about
who you're going to be the reason why
this is so important to start doing
every single morning is because if you
don't consciously decide who you're
going to be
your habits your old patterns and the
stress of the day will decide it for you
you see human beings this was so
liberating when I learned that human
beings are nothing more than a ton of
patterns
we learn patterns from other people and
then we repeat those patterns and so if
you find that you're stuck in a rut or
you're overwhelmed or you're in a
negative place and you are really tired
of being there the first step to getting
the life that you want is you must wake
up every morning and interrupt the
patterns and the automatic nature of how
you go through your day just going
through the motions and the simplest way
to do that is to wake up and set an
intention so when I say decide who
you're going to be what I'm talking
about is
how are you going to behave
what are you going to show up and do
today
are you going to be motivated are you
going to be patient are you going to be
present are you going to be grateful
those are decisions that you can make
and when you wake up in the morning and
you set an intention today today I am
going to see the good
today I am going to be optimistic today
I'm going to turn off the television
when I get home I'm going to spend an
hour on my dreams when you wake up and
set an intention and you decide who
you're going to be today and how you're
going to show up and what it's going to
feel like to be you you take control of
the day
and you give yourself an anchor to keep
coming back to so that when something
stresses you out or you catch yourself
thinking negative things or you get a a
text or somebody doesn't respond to you
and you start to feel discouraged come
back to your intention today I said I
would opt to be optimistic today I said
I would see the good today I said no
matter how tired I am when I get home
tonight I'm going to find an hour for me
that's what I mean night queen bee when
I say decide who you're gonna be today
self-worth I gave myself a nine because
you know I've done the work one of the
reasons why I think what we talk about
really resonates with you is that it's
real
I didn't read this in some book and now
I'm curating it for you this is all
stuff that we've tried that has been
Road tested that has been earned through
the ups and downs of life and I also
offer up everything that I say to you
not as a mandate even though sometimes
I'm incredibly impassionate or
passionate about what I'm saying
but I offer it up as something for you
to consider because at the end of the
day it's your life
and you get to choose how you want to
live it you get to choose whether or not
you're going to suffer through it you
get to choose whether or not you're
going to be happy through it you get to
choose whether or not you're going to
continue to live with the stories from
your past or whether or not you're going
to update them and change for the better
because
um you're the one that will reap the
benefits or suffer the consequences and
so any passion comes from the fact that
I used to be a miserable person I used
to hate myself I used to destroy
relationships because of my own
self-loathing and I still have some work
to do you know I was talking to Tara a
very good friend of ours who is also my
favorite yoga instructor
and
um she was talking today about how she
just felt really sad and I was saying to
her I can relate to that because while
I'm very fulfilled I feel disconnected
and I still have parts of my life where
I don't like myself and I think that's
normal and there are parts of my life
where I still have armor up and this is
the year even though I've spent a decade
really digging deep and curing my
anxiety and
identifying the limiting beliefs that I
have and trying to be deliberate about
updating the story that I have that I
tell myself about myself
and that I don't deserve it that nobody
likes me that I'm not doing a good job
that at some point this is all going to
disappear
um
that you know I don't matter all those
just crappy things that you say to
yourself and so I've done a lot of work
and so while my self-worth is at a nine
I'm very proud of the work I still have
a lot of work to do and so this is going
to be a year where I go deeper and what
does that mean I don't know yet it
probably means that I I think I'd like
to try to find a therapist I think it'd
be really cool especially as I'm taking
on all these things that are more
confronting
um it means that I want to do more
listening I'm going to do a lot of
talking but a little less talking and a
little more listening
um I want to consume more content
instead of being focused on creating it
that's been a big missing for me is you
know I stand up on a lot of stages and
speak I'd like to sit in an audience and
listen here and there
um and be more deliberate about my own
development because there's still a lot
that I gotta learn and as we create as
we take on new challenges in this
company and again what direction is life
going forward
and as life goes forward and as our
business goes forward and as
opportunities come and they go and as
some things are successful and some
things are a disaster
um it's going to require me to go deeper
and so that's what I'm going to be
deliberate about so my body micro
exercise my work is about a digital
Focus my money is about socking money
away personally and about
um also diversifying income streams
business-wise my love life is being more
deliberate so a date a week with Chris
he has the flu right now so I'm not
going near him it's not going to happen
today uh friendships being a better
friend and my self-worth going deeper
I'm sure you've heard the advice that in
order to grow and be a happier person
you have got to cut the toxic people out
of your life you know it seems like
everyone online is saying it right now
spend time with
you got to defend your light with your
life and generally I agree with that
advice I I think I even told you that
you need to do a friend cleanse when
people get negative I got no time for
negativity especially from people online
but there's a major difference between a
toxic person online and a toxic friend
or family member in real life
look if the toxic person is online or
it's an acquaintance from a long time
ago that's easy just hit delete
because there's absolutely no reason why
you should tolerate anything but
positive hilarious and inspiring content
in your social media feeds in fact I
personally unfollow people all week long
and I've even noticed that as my goals
and my priorities change the accounts
that I follow change too but let's talk
about the harder issue how do you
unfriend someone in real life
first of all if it's a friend or family
member that's starting to rub you the
wrong way don't be an ass don't ghost
people don't ignore them
that behavior is not only cowardly it is
also toxic on your part too when you
have somebody in your life that is toxic
it's an opportunity for you to grow
because this person didn't start off
toxic they probably turned toxic when
somebody turns toxic it almost always is
a sign that there's something either
wrong with them or there's something
going on with you
so before you unfriend someone in real
life I want you to stop and make sure
you've done your part of being a friend
now there's a simple two-part test that
you should give yourself before you
unfriend somebody here's what you do
step one ask yourself what emotion comes
up for me worry and concern
or is it resentment and annoyance
if it's worry and concern that comes up
for you when you think about this person
very simple answer on your hands here
pick up the phone and just Reach Out
but if what's coming up for you when you
think about this person is resentment
and annoyance it's time for you to go a
little deeper to step two the second
thing I want you to do is I want you to
ask yourself
why are you annoyed
why do you resent this person and look
if you're annoyed because they're a
shallow backstabbing
and their behavior is violating your
values and boundaries easy unfriend
however even the animals in your life
can teach you something if you look a
little deeper when you ask yourself the
question why am I so annoyed by this
person
there's almost always something going on
with you because there's a lot of jerks
in the world that you're going to bump
into that don't trigger you at all but
there's something about this person
that's striking something deeper that
you need to deal with
you're triggered and a trigger is always
an opportunity for you to heal something
unfriending somebody is the easy way out
but when you do it you miss out on a
powerful moment of self-reflection and
growth
the fact is the negativity that you're
feeling the resentment the annoyance the
Judgment it's toxic inside of you
and so giving yourself a moment before
you unfriend that is powerful because
the negativity you feel the resentment
the toxicity it disappears when you stop
yourself from throwing in the towel and
you choose to throw yourself and your
friend a Lifeline instead and here's the
reason why it's so important for you to
stop and reflect for real friendships
are a give and take and you are a part
of the give and take
and if you give this friend the cold
shoulder you're going to take this
pattern of ghosting people and
unfriending people
and deciding that people are toxic into
every future friendship that you create
and I promise you whatever it is that's
triggering you right now in this friend
that you're pissed off about it's going
to show up in friends in the future
this is a pattern in your life and with
all patterns they repeat unless you
break them apart and replace them so
once you've checked in with yourself
check in with your friend
it's as easy as picking up the phone and
saying hello and what do you say how do
you do this you just lead with kindness
you can apologize for how you've
contributed to the distance between the
two of you say I've missed you their
response will tell you everything you
need to know about the friendship and
honestly what happens to the Friendship
is beside the point by choosing to check
in
before you unfriend it tells me
everything
that I need to know about you by hitting
Pause by self-reflecting that's the work
that you do to become a better friend to
yourself fear is real but I am going to
share a secret weapon that I have used
for years to beat every single fear that
used to stop me you're going to use my
five second rule in combination with
what I call an anchor thought
and that is going to reframe
what your mind is doing so that your
mind goes from feeling agitation and
making you afraid to reframing it from
agitation to excitement it works like
magic now I have used this technique for
years literally for years and one of the
ways that I want to introduce you to it
is I want to take you backstage
I want to take you backstage to a speech
that I delivered this year and what
you're going to see is you're going to
see me behind you know the major set I'm
about to walk out you can kind of hear
the crowd roaring my introductory video
is playing my body is in a state of
arousal I am literally my heart is
racing my arms are sweating like it's
like you're going to see this I'm going
to tell you about it and you're going to
watch me use this same technique I'm
going to teach you to reframe my nerves
into excitement check this out all right
I'm about to go on stage there are 7 000
people out there and it's so exciting
because
what they don't know is they're about to
learn the five second rule and their
lives will never be the same again now I
gotta tell you my heart is racing
um my armpits are sweating
I have the exact same physiological
feeling is when I'm afraid but I'm not
afraid I'm excited excitement and fear
is the exact same thing in your body
it's just what your brain calls it
here's a trick that's proven by science
that I use every time I speak when I
start to sweat when I start to have
butterflies when I start to have my
heart race I say I'm excited I'm excited
to get out there I'm excited to talk to
these people I'm excited to share the
five second rule and what that does is
it sends a message to my brain that
tells my brain why my body's all
agitated and excited and that way I
don't feel afraid remember excitement
and fear exact same thing in your body
the only difference is what your brain
calls two wins is a way to practice
gratitude
um and to train yourself
to start to
see what's going right in your life
celebrate and claim the wins
that you see in your life and
also claim the wins that you want to
create in the future so here's the way
that Chris and I have been doing it
Chris and I every single day whether
we're taking a walk in the morning or
we're sitting having coffee in the
morning or we do it with our kids uh at
dinner at night we've done it with
friends it's starting to spread like
wildfire through my company as
everybody's taking it on because it's
really fun and here is the simple way
you do two wins you ready
[Music]
uh two ends the way that we've been
doing it is you
I know I'm going on and on and on I'm a
little add right now we just got out of
the house for a three day the way we've
been doing it wrong oh the way we've
been the first let me tell you how we've
been doing it
we have been telling ourselves and each
other
what's one win in the last 90 days
and what is a win that you've had in the
last 24 hours
and what I love about it as I explained
on this video that we did on Instagram
that went crazy viral and you guys had
all kinds of questions about
is
um
he had questions about
do you have to say it out loud yes you
do because part of it is not just
thinking it it's starting to express it
and allowing somebody else in your life
to hear it so that they can hold space
for your wins and help you celebrate too
but the peace that we've been missing
Chris
is we've been missing the piece
that is the third part so 90 days last
24 hours you need to claim the win you
want to create
in the next 90 days pretty cool huh
eyes on the road
yeah and that can change every day and
so that was one of the big questions
when you celebrate your wins you do your
three wins that's what we're calling it
three wins we were calling it two wins
but this is now called the three wins as
you
speak what your wins are past 90 days
past 24 hours you then claim and speak
what you want your win to be and are
going to work four in the next 90 days
I love this I love this claiming your
wins so Chris and I are going to do this
right now so that you can watch how we
do it three wins yes we are
so in the last 90 days a big win for me
[Music]
uh
uh oh
having a daughter who is starting her
senior year in college
and who seems so happy
that we have not heard from her
literally in like five days and that's a
huge win because normally I hear from
her every day but when she's happy and
busy we don't hear from her so that's a
big win for me last 24 hours
big win
or not even a big win a small one
a small win is that I've gotten into the
car here with Chris and we are heading
uh
we're heading out to celebrate our 26th
wedding anniversary away for three
nights
um I will take
um responsibility for the fact that I
saw the road please I'd like to get
there but you're so beautiful oh that's
a win but my husband just complimented
me
um wow no but I am two hours late we
thought we would leave by 1 15. it is 3
15. so it's a big win that I'm in the
car
at about to have three days with Chris
and now I'm gonna claim a win in the
next 90 days
a win I'm gonna claim in the next 90
days
I feel like this anniversary is a big
anniversary for us
26 years
especially after what has been a really
hard two years
and in the next 90 days the win that I'm
going to claim
is that
we're going to look at each other and go
oh my God we have launched a whole new
chapter in our marriage
and it's the best most exciting
amazing
sexy fabulous one yet
[Music]
this idea that
you don't ever start
you stay trapped in your head and if you
feel paralyzed if you've been spinning
the same ideas over and over and over
again then you know what I'm talking
about you see many of you are thinking
way too big you're attaching way too
much pressure on the things that you're
interested in until you start blogging
about fashion you won't even know if you
like it so thinking that you have a
dream about doing it and thinking that
you have this grand plan that you're
going to do it full time it is a
complete and utter waste of your time to
be dreaming that big and let me tell you
why because oftentimes if you're the
kind of person like Vicki that's getting
trapped up here the bigness of what
you're thinking about is what's stopping
you what I want you to do if you're in
Vicki's situation is I want you to stop
dreaming and I want you to just start
doing small things I want you to go back
to curiosity and less into crushing your
big goals thing about life and business
and success is that you have to be
willing to start and for people that
procrastinate starting is the hardest
part for people that worry for people
that think too big starting is the
hardest part folks that study
procrastination talk about the fact that
the only way to beat procrastination is
to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to push yourself
to get started because all the research
shows that if we can push you to get
started on something you'll likely keep
going I woke up this morning and I was
feeling really anxious
and what that means for me is the second
that I wake up my heart is racing
and I start feeling like something's
wrong
and I know this feeling because I've had
anxiety for decades
it doesn't come around that much anymore
but when it does takes me right back
so I wanted to just grab the phone and
show you what I do when I wake up
feeling anxious first of all rule number
one do not under any circumstances lay
in bed if you wake up and you feel
anxious about something you have got to
use the five second rule five four three
two one get up get out of bed
yet moving because if you can get up you
can get going if you can get going you
can get dressed if you can get dressed
you can move your body if you can move
your body you can then move your
emotions if you can move your emotions
you can then move your mind if you can
move your mind you can move your mood so
one thing leads to another number one
get up do it anyway is a mindset trick
that you can use when you start to feel
excuses rolling up it works a lot like
the five second rule so you have said to
yourself okay I'm going to talk to my
boss today about that thing that I've
been avoiding talking to them about
or maybe you've said something like I'm
gonna go to the gym today or tomorrow or
whatever and then the moment comes where
you've got to have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym and what always happens
you don't feel like it
I bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that damn
I'm not going to have a drink tonight
and then guess what happens when you get
home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments when there are things in my life
that I really want to do
I need to do
I should do but when the moment comes I
don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside I said I would go
for a short run I don't feel like it I'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning I'm tired it's cold
I laid out my yoga clothes but now I
don't feel like it what do I do I do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
I'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what I'm gonna do it anyway
your brain doesn't know the difference
between an event that you have closed
your eyes and imagined
and an event that you've actually done
and so here's what's really cool
what I just told you
is manifesting
seriously
manifesting
done correctly
is when you use your procedural memory
as a tool
to train your brain your nervous system
your spirit to help you feel motivated
and to help you do the work that
actually changes your life
how cool is that
I want to be very clear about something
you know manifesting gets a bad rap
because of the law of attraction
but manifesting is not woo-woo at all
it's not a Cheesy topic manifesting is
not just think about something that you
want and suddenly it'll magically appear
no no no no no
manifesting is when you use your
procedural memory and you visualize the
step by step by step actions
that you need to take in order to make
your big goal or the thing that you want
or the new habit to become a reality you
see manifesting isn't the end everybody
manifesting is the bridge it's the
series of actions that you're gonna take
in order to have this new habit when I
hear the word leadership I think about
influence so let's first talk about what
is the word influence actually mean okay
so influence is the power that you have
to affect the actions behaviors and
opinions of other people in short it
means you have the influence to move
somebody from point A
to point B
now there are two kinds of influence
that all leaders have
internal influence
and that's the power that you have over
yourself
and in my opinion this type of influence
is the single most important type of
influenced practice and cultivate that
will impact your ability to impact
others internal influence is your
ability to move yourself from point A to
point B
because one of the things about being a
great leader is knowing how to be
flexible knowing how to change knowing
how to Pivot knowing how to grow and
that means you've got to have influence
over yourself the other type of
influence is external influence and that
is your ability to move other people
from point A to point B you know we all
have had these experiences right where
we've uh been around other leaders we've
been around people that have had that
implied influence right because of their
position because of their title but I
guarantee you you've had the experience
where you've had to work for or been
around another leader
but they have not been that influential
on you
they were either a jerk or a
micromanager or they showed up in a way
that made you feel awful you have had
that experience and one of the reasons
why I want to hammer home this point
that it doesn't matter who you are where
you are what you do leadership the best
kind of leadership and the most powerful
kind of influence is the type that's
earned it has nothing to do with your
position it has nothing to do with your
title it has everything to do
with how you show up and the way in
which you treat other people I want you
to understand that the most important
aspect of raising your influence and of
becoming a better and a more influential
leader is
deciding that you want to be
and claiming that that leadership role
in your life when you look at leadership
and Brendan's right it's super important
that you're a student your whole life
that leadership is something that you
should study when you start to look into
leadership you're going to see that
there's all kinds of books there's all
kinds of philosophies there are servant
based leaders there are transformational
leaders there are situational leaders
there are people who are authoritarian
leaders there's a bazillion different
leadership styles well what I want you
to think about is what kind of leader do
you want to be and there are two
questions that I think are important for
you to ask yourself and the reason why
it's important for you to ask yourself
these two questions is because they will
give you a road map that maps to your
values and maps to your goals and maps
to who you are in terms of cultivating a
leadership style my definition of
confidence is not belief in self
what you're going to learn about Mel
Robbins is that I love evidence-based
advice
because I'm kind of skeptical
now I was trained as a lawyer life has
kicked me up kicked me around a little
bit I kind of crossed my eyes at people
that are very kind of motivational
and you know I'm like well it's easy to
do the inspirational stuff but what's
the depth right what's the depth
and so when I think about confidence and
my definition of confidence I looked at
the research on confidence okay and
there's really good news here the first
thing you've already learned it's a
skill
the second thing that you are going to
learn that's really good is it's it's
very simple to build the skill of
confidence and you can do it through
repetitive actions every day very simple
little things that will slowly build up
the reservoir of confidence and here's
the definition I want to give you of
confidence
confidence is the willingness to try
that's it
I'm going to say it again
confidence is the willingness to try
that's it
that's all that it is and the reason why
I like this definition is because this
definition that I have created for
confidence which is the willingness to
try
is based in the research around
confidence
so if you want to learn more about this
Google
confidence
competency Loop okay I'm going to show
it to you I'm hoping that that this is
not broadcasting backwards okay this is
my fancy little graphic okay this is
what we call a confidence competency
Loop
I did not invent this this is something
that people who research confidence for
a living have created
and I've highlighted this because this
is where confidence begins it begins
with the willingness to try because I'm
going to show you what ends up happening
if you're the kind of person
who trains yourself notice the words I'm
using trains we're not going to sit
around and wait for motivation we're not
going to wait for courage we're going to
manufacture those things and this is
where the five second rule is so
transformative
now for those of you that don't know it
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
explaining it I'm going to give it give
you the shortcut it's just a simple
brain hack backed by tremendous evidence
that I created at the worst moment of my
life that turns out to have
extraordinary science behind it
all you do is in a moment where you feel
doubt insecurity fear anxiety
procrastination perfectionism PTSD OCD
anything that you might possibly have
that would rise up to block you you
simply count backwards five four three
two one okay and you gotta count
backwards five four three two one and
what that will do is it will shift gears
in your mind instead of being stuck here
in the part of the brain that keeps you
stuck worrying and thinking and having a
bias towards overthinking and being a
perfectionist you're going to go
one-fourth or five four three two one
and you're going to try
now this is what's going to happen
the first time you try you will fail
that's really good news you want to know
why you learn by failing
you learn by failing
do you realize that's how you've always
learned
that when you were a kid you don't
remember this but when you were learning
to walk
you fell an average of 17 times an hour
you actually learned to walk by Falling
and so you learn everything when you
fail because when you fail as much as
you may think you're gonna die if you
stand on a stage I see a lot of you who
want to be coaches or speakers or
whatever you're going to have to learn
how to give a speech where you stutter
and where your your mouth gets really
dry and pasty and where you get a neck
rash and where you forget what you're
supposed to say you got to do all that
stuff why because when you fail you
don't die you actually gain knowledge
and experience
and that's the gift of failure because
you then take that knowledge and that
experience and you go right back to the
next time and then you try again but
this time when you five four three two
one try
you're going to take your knowledge and
experience with you and you're going to
fail a little bit less and what you're
going to learn there you're going to
take right back to the next time that
you try and every time that you fail
you're gaining knowledge and experience
and you take that to the next time that
you try and you're gonna go like this
and you're gonna go like this and you're
going to keep going and going and going
and going and going and every time
you five four three two one
you push yourself to try
you gain a little bit of Competency for
the next time you're going to do it and
every time you gain a little bit of
Competency your Mastery goes up
and that's when you start to feel more
self-assured
and that muscle everybody of trying
that is where you build the skill of
confidence which is the willingness to
not be so damn serious and hung up on
being perfect and being worried about
looking stupid and instead you're
willing to lean in and try something we
tend to think about fear as something
that's up here you know that the fears
are all in our heads well the truth is
your body feels fear and remembers fear
and senses fear way before your mind
does and the reason why I want to talk
to you about this is because as many of
you know we have a brand new audiobook
that just launched with audible
Originals so audible Originals is an
imprint inside of audible we are our
major partner of audibles and we just
released a brand new audiobook it's
their number one new release on Audible
called take control of your life how to
silence fear and win the men mental game
and there were some unbelievable things
that I learned and that my team learned
and that we're now sharing with you in
doing that project so take control of
your life isn't your typical audiobook
it's not me just reading a book that I
wrote what take control of your life is
is take control of your life is a live
coaching and takeaway program that's 10
hours long and so there are six people
that you meet when you listen to take
control of your life and they have fears
just like you have fears fears that are
holding them back just like you have
fears that hold you back fears that
impact your life in a negative way and
we go session by session for six
sessions you listen to the coaching
session you hear about somebody else's
fear you hear me coaching this person
live and then I spend like 45 minutes
unpacking the entire coaching session
for you and on top of it you guys
there's a 55-page workbook that our team
design that goes along as a companion to
this audiobook and you don't even need
to buy the audiobook to get the workbook
or to get the takeaways because I'm
giving you the takeaways for free here
on our live stream so if you want the
audiobook just go to melrobbins.com take
control and you can download the
audiobook and what I'm going to talk to
you about today is I'm going to talk to
you about the session that we did with
Heather in take control of your life and
it's a really incredible
um session because Heather
um is held back at work because what
happens is when she has to have a really
difficult conversation when there's
something that she wants to talk to her
boss about when there's a conflict with
one of her colleagues you ever have a
conflict with your colleagues at work
ever feel like you work in a toxic work
environment well this is something that
you need to understand
sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment is about the other people
and sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment or in your life environment
or your friend environment is about
stored memories in your body from your
childhood I know it's crazy stuff
because the saying Feel the fear and do
it anyway it's true because your body
feels situations that set you uh
that puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that I
want to teach you today is that if you
start to tune into your body and you
start to notice the signals that your
body is sending to you in your
day-to-day life signals like butterflies
in your stomach signals like feeling A
Rush of energy up to your neck signals
like your armpit sweating signals like
your hands getting sweaty signals that
your body is stepping and noticing a
situation that reminds it of your past
learning how to read those signals that
oh my God here goes my body my body is
starting to recognize that this is a
situation that puts me on edge
recognizing those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God that is a
critical skill in taking control of your
life I want to tell you a little bit
about the science so there's this famous
Neuroscience it's called Antonio demacio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger
speaking to your boss calling a prospect
going to the gym when you're not proud
of the way that you look
um and you know it's not fear like
Terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body I felt it
yesterday because I went to a boot camp
class yesterday and I'm not in good
shape and I don't do boot camp classes
and Kendall and I are staying at this
hotel where holy cow everybody seems
like there's some sort of professional
weight lifter or Instagram model and so
it was really intimidating and I could
feel
that agitation in my body that's the
kind of fear I'm talking about I'm not
talking about the paralysis fear your
life is threatened and you really are in
a life or death situation I'm talking
about the low-grade agitation
that is
um there when you're about to do
something that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable so when fear or dangerous
sensed in the body your body begins a
stress response before your mind even
catches up and if you want to take
control of your life you got to take
control of that physical state and it
starts with catching these moments
everyone
when you
um start to feel it okay and so for some
of you it may be a pit in the stomach
for some of you it may be tightening in
the chest for Heather who was one of the
people I coached and take control it was
this massive wave of heat that went into
her chest tightness or rash and then she
could start to feel that she was crying
you need to understand how do you react
to situations that make you nervous you
do have the power to create a better
life you are not meant to White Knuckle
your way through this thing you're not
meant to be in survival mode you deserve
to be a happier person and you are
capable of identifying your goals and
chipping away at them and you are
capable my friend of dreaming big and
once you can visualize those big dreams
of yours you can put your head down and
you can make those things happen if
you're willing to put in the work I want
you to imagine a brand new possibility
for your life
and if you like Sarah can say I want to
be happy I want the next chapter of my
life to be amazing if you can just even
start there
all you have to do is start to think
about what kind of a map do you need in
order to chart a course to make that
possibility that you see for your life a
reality
and I love this topic of reinvention I
love it love it love it because I have
this metaphor that I've been using for
years when it comes to understanding
reinvention
and what is the metaphor the metaphor
that I use is a road trip that's right
life is one big road trip and we're
going to use this metaphor of a road
trip to demystify the entire concept and
process of Reinventing yourself or
Reinventing Your Life And for those of
you that have listened to my number one
ranked audio series on Audible called
reinventure life you have heard me talk
about this metaphor and this is such a
powerful concept because the fact is
life is a journey
it's one big road trip and for too many
of us that road trip is boring and
monotonous and I want to shake things up
I want your life to be the most exciting
exhilarating amazing road trip that you
could possibly imagine and we're all on
this big road trip we all began at the
exact same mile marker zero
every single year of your life is
another mile marker on this twisting
amazing journey called life for me I'm
at mild marker 54. that is how far down
the road I am and so I want you to stop
and just think okay well what mile
marker am I at right now and it's a
useful exercise to think about it that
way because when I say to you hey
I'm at mile marker 54. that tells me
that there's a lot of road that I've
covered behind me but guess what
there is a huge open road ahead of me
and when you take responsibility
for charting that course of where that
open road is going to lead you
you take control of your life that's
what reinvention is all about it's about
creating a map picking a destination and
charting your course on this road called
life and here's what's exciting about
that you get to choose you get to choose
how fast you're going to drive whether
you're going to take the highway whether
you're going to twist and turn where you
want to go next I know that I have to
take care of me so I can take care of
others but I just have a hard time doing
it without feeling that guilt to me it
literally feels like a child learning to
walk I don't know how to do it without
feeling guilt I want to remove that
guilt from inside of me
Janet I got some bad news
you can't remove the guilt
I'm gonna say that again
when you first start putting yourself
first you will not remove the guilt
and so I just want to be honest about
that but let me give you the two
takeaways okay that are really important
because this really isn't about guilt
this is about you defining for yourself
what it means to be a good wife and a
good mother and a good person in your
eyes and so I'm gonna give you two major
wake-up calls that I had around this
topic and then I'm going to tell you
this crazy story so the first
wake-up call that I got is this notion
that the people who love you
they will be annoyed with you when you
put yourself first it is true they are
not going to like it they like you being
the person that you are right now it is
convenient for them that you put them
first it is wonderful the dynamic that's
in place but it's no longer good for you
so just expect that the people who you
love will be annoyed or disappointed or
upset when you start putting yourself
first
but they're still going to love you
it's not an either or thing and I'll
explain more about that
and second this is a huge wake-up call
what if the guilt doesn't go away
what if guilt is actually a good thing
what if guilt is super healthy to feel
right now
in fact that's what I believe
I believe that the guilt is good I
believe that the guilt is healthy and I
believe that you can reframe it
see Guilt shows that you care that's why
you feel that way if you are a
narcissistic douchebag you wouldn't feel
guilty at all for putting yourself first
I want to frame guilt in a different way
for you okay
let's frame it from a bad sign oh I'm
doing something bad I'm putting myself
first into a good one stop seeing guilt
is a bad thing because you're not doing
anything wrong when you put yourself
first
start seeing guilt as a good thing guilt
is a sign that you're breaking free of
this people-pleasing habit
you feel guilty because putting yourself
first is just a new feeling that's it
your excuses are both
that's right
all those excuses you got
they're just fear
they are just fear
when you learn the lesson when you turn
toward the friction in your life and you
look for either the process or the
people or the place that you're living
or the place that you work
all of the things the thinking patterns
that you have the behavior patterns when
you start to identify everybody all of
the areas of friction in your life
and you go to work to learn the lesson
here's what I want you to know you are
capable of changing it
you are 100 capable of learning the
lesson and making anything in your life
better
I know that is true about you and that
means that the only thing that is
keeping you
from identifying the things that aren't
working and doing the work to move your
life into alignment with who you're
meant to be and the things that truly
make you come alive the only thing
that's preventing you from doing that is
you
and your fears whether you're like any
excuse that you have is just fear
you're afraid to try you're afraid to
fail you're afraid you're too late
you're afraid of this you're afraid of
that now's not the right time I don't
have this I don't have that this person
would be upset with me all of it is fear
fear of rejection fear of it not working
out fear of disobeying being
disappointed fear of disappointing
others that's what an excuse is you're
just managing fear and it's all baloney
every single time you're procrastinating
it's being triggered by stress
see that's the crazy thing about
procrastination it has nothing to do
with what you need to do
procrastination defined in the
dictionary is avoiding or putting
something off delaying it but when you
look at the research and we're going to
dig into that in a minute the way that
researchers Define procrastination is
that you are avoiding
stress
that's what you're avoiding you're not
avoiding the application you're not
avoiding the illustration
you blow off things that take brain
power because you are trying to avoid
stress procrastination is the attempt to
feel better in this moment
and strangely what you're about to learn
is that when I walk you through this
three-step research-backed technique
that you're going to use every single
time that you catch yourself
procrastinating is that procrastination
is triggered by stress
that's what it's about
I'm going to say that again
procrastination is a habit that you have
learned
and that you repeat whenever you feel
stressed and this comes from research
from Dr Timothy pikel at Carleton
University his definition of
procrastination is this a subconscious
desire to feel good right now
and he shares that procrastination it's
just all about stress and I'm going to
unpack this for you because when you
first hear that wait procrastination is
a subconscious desire to feel good right
now how the heck does that make sense I
mean vidi really wants to draw Mel
so wouldn't it make sense that she'd
feel good if she were drawing
sort of
and I'm going to explain this it makes
sense intellectually but when I unpack
how stress is triggering you to stop
doing something that you care about or
that you need to do this is all going to
be like holy cow why didn't I hear this
sooner
so I'm going to give you an example
but I want you to understand that that
stress that is triggering you to
procrastinate it could be something
going on in your life right now or it
could be deep seated stress like
childhood trauma it could be anxiety or
depression or something in your past
that you haven't dealt with a situation
that you're worried about that's
completely unrelated to work or to the
things that you need to do it might just
be the Relentless pressure and stress
that you feel because you are so hard on
yourself and something that I definitely
struggle with is with masking and you
know being afraid to show up as my true
authentic self and to all people at all
times yeah just any advice would be
amazing on how to just
get better at doing that and have the
confidence to just be my authentic true
self
um all the time that would be great and
thank you Nella thank you first and
foremost for your honesty
um
but I'm going to say something a little
provocative
you kept saying the words true authentic
self authentic self authentic self and I
want you to stop and ask yourself do you
even know who you are
do you know what it means when you say I
am my true authentic self
and the reason why I'm asking you this
question is because I don't think most
people do
I think we want to be our we want to be
our authentic selves of course but what
does that even mean
you know listening to your question it
reminds me when I was writing the high
five habit there was a woman who wrote
To Me from Ireland and I ended up
getting on the phone and then on a zoom
call and I spent a lot of time talking
to her and she is in the book and I want
to bring this up because I want to make
a point about the pressure that we feel
to conform
so in this example of the woman from
Ireland she was writing about the fact
that she wanted to get a divorced
that is her true authentic self
yet she had been delaying doing this for
seven years because of the pressure of
the Catholic church because of the
disappointment of her mother because of
what the priest might think because of
what the whole freaking country of
Ireland might think
and so I'm highlighting this because for
some of us people pleasing is even
deeper than sort of this discomfort it's
the social Norm
like you wouldn't be caught dead
In some cultures or in some religions or
in some households veering from the norm
the pressure is so intense it's just the
air that you breathe
and for many people that is the case and
so if that's you
you might not even know what the
authentic you is because you have been
told for so long by your country by your
religion by your family by the community
you live in by whatever
who you're supposed to be
and I'm going to give you a really
important exercise I want you to just
imagine that you are a screenwriter
that you are about to write a movie
about the real you
write a character description
and describe a day in the life of the
real you
remove the country you live in remove
the religion you grew up with or you
didn't remove the stories that you've
been telling yourself or the pressure
you feel or the disappointment or what
other people think you should or
shouldn't do
and write the story a day in the life
of who you are at your core
when you would wake up where you would
live
where you would go what kind of work you
do what kind of friends that you have
what are your habits what do you love
doing who are you laughing with
this is such an important exercise
because again remember I told you that
people pleasing
it's a balance
and it begins with you truly knowing
yourself
and if you don't really know who you are
because you've always been told who to
be and you've spent your life feeling
like you do nothing but conforming this
is a really important step for you to
take
because people pleasing at its core is
you believing the person that you are
deep inside that it's not good enough
you're not good enough
and based on what we've talked about you
can start to change that but you really
have to go through the steps of getting
curious about who you are for real you
gotta stop comparing yourself to people
whose lives don't look like yours
you will never be able to achieve
what somebody who is a single male can
achieve because you've got other demands
on your time right now you will never be
able to achieve what a 23 year old can
do right now because you've got aging
parents and three kids and a business to
run
and so please
please stop making yourself feel like
because you are looking at somebody who
has totally different life circumstances
than you and by the way this does not
mean that there's something wrong with a
23 year old Fitness influencer I think
that's freaking fantastic that
somebody's doing that with their life
there's nothing wrong with somebody who
is going on a book tour for three months
I think that's fantastic and there's
clearly a part of me that wants to do
more of that but at the moment
I gotta face reality and the reality is
based on my values based on what life
looks like right now
I'm not going to do that but what I can
do is figure out what advice I respond
to what changes I want to make and then
I can fit that into my life how can I
get started on my dreams and make them a
reality where do I start Mel there's so
much self-doubt it's overwhelming and I
just don't know where to begin once
somebody knows what they want to change
or why they want to change it the next
big question is how and so I'm going to
answer Jessica's question in two parts
because there are two parts to how
the first part is easy it's the doing
part
and how you get started when it comes to
taking action and you don't know what to
quote do
this is easy
just go to Google
I'm I'm dead serious about this
Google has the answer to everything if
you simply go to Google or go to YouTube
and type in the change you want to make
or the goal that you have or the thing
that you want to create in your life you
will probably get 6.3 million search
results and every single one of the
links that you click on will give you a
long list of things that you could
probably do and I'm not being a smart
ass here
the fact is
the steps that you need to take action
wise are super simple
the reason why you're stuck is because
of the second part of her question
now did you notice she said at the very
end
my self-doubt my self-depth because one
of the reasons why
you get stuck is because of the doubt
and this is where working on your dreams
and your goals gets really tricky
because if your own mindset is working
against you you're actually never going
to feel inspired or motivated or
encouraged to take the actions that that
Google result just told you to take
and so we gotta focus on your mindset
first and foremost when it comes to
where do I start
because I want to play this out with you
let's just role play here
if you're sitting there going
I would love to become an opera singer
but I don't know but self-doubt but what
if I sound stupid but this but that but
what if Uncle Willie's if you start
doubting your ability to make that
happen
how motivated do you feel
if you're sitting there telling yourself
that you can't do it or that it's not
going to work
this is the reason why
most people never even get started on
their goals and dreams their thinking
pattern is the problem because their
self-doubt their perfectionism their
lack of self-worth it's convincing you
not to take the action what is the five
second rule it's a form of metacognition
that gives you immediate control over
your thoughts and actions using the rule
is so simple the moment you feel your
instincts fire up just start counting
backwards to yourself to switch the
gears in your mind
54321 then give yourself a push forward
counting backwards requires focus and
when you focus your prefrontal cortex
awakens and by the way that's the part
of the brain that helps you learn new
positive behavior patterns I first
mentioned the rule in a TED talk since
then more than eight million people have
discovered the rule through that talk
and its powerful countdown trick to take
control of their lives become more
confident happy and even make their
dreams come true now first let's talk a
little bit about productivity as a
concept productivity is not about
blasting through your to-do list and
doing more it's actually about doing
less productivity is the ability to make
progress in the things that matter to
you
it sounds simple right I mean just move
the ball down the field on the important
stuff but it's not easy why blame your
feelings you see you're capable of being
more productive you're just waiting to
feel like doing what you need to do and
guess what you're never going to crack
the whip on yourself when you have a
million other things that you need to do
and you got people that are making
demands on you
one thing that you must understand is
that you have the power to decide what's
important
and productivity actually boils down to
simple five second decisions
here's one that you need to start making
immediately that will have a tremendous
impact on your ability to be productive
when the alarm goes off
do you wake up early to work on your
business or do you blow it off because
you don't feel like it you're tired or
do you stick to the plan to finish some
important tasks or be a Mainline
Facebook instead because ah you'd just
rather relax when you change your
decisions you'll change everything
because productivity boils down to the
ability to make small five-second
decisions that put the things that are
important first and here's one five
second decision that will make you more
productive than any other get up 30
minutes earlier than you normally do and
push yourself to work on the most
important priorities first
this isn't just me research shows that
your most productive hours are the first
two to three hours after you wake up and
get ready this means that for Peak
productivity you've got to do whatever
you can do to make sure the most
important work to you gets done first
during that window of time so here's how
you're going to use the rule the moment
your alarm goes off and you want to hit
the snooze button use the rule 54321
push yourself out of bed then use the
rule again 54321 sit down and get
working on the things that matter to you
instead of checking your phone instead
of letting your day get hijacked you see
the moment you feel yourself wanting to
give in to distraction you're going to
use the rule again
54321 do a search control and get back
on task to the things that matter to you
it doesn't really matter how busy you
are we're all busy if you really care
you'll find the time and that's how
you're going to use the rule to find the
time to work on things that matter to
you if you feel stuck right now if you
feel like you're in a rut if you just
got dumped or fired or you're going
through a divorce or you put on more
weight than you've ever had or you're
just feeling kind of lost in life you
have no clue what you want to do
here's a tip from your friend Mel
Robbins
if you don't know what to do in that
situation sign up for something
challenging
train for a marathon
commit to doing something that feels
hard as hell and that pushes you outside
of your comfort zone something that
forces you to add something new to your
life like a training run every single
day or a class where you're going to
learn something or a meditation
Challenger hell 75 harder how about this
one if you don't know how to swim and
you're an adult
it'd be pretty confronting to go to your
local Y and sign up for an adult
beginner swim class and learn how to
swim which is a life-saving skill
or maybe you want to sign up for Tango
lessons and you've always thought about
how fun it would be to dance in
competitions see what's interesting
about a challenge of something scary and
hard is it forces you to level up every
area of your life because you won't be
successful adding this challenge into
your life and completing the goal if you
don't change your life and your habits
and the systems of your day-to-day life
in order to be a person who can achieve
this goal it literally shocks you to
your core when you sign up for a
challenge and it reminds you
I'm more powerful than I think I'm not
stuck in this situation or this
relationship or this dead-end job I'm
more powerful than I think and just
trying this online challenge or training
for this Marathon or this you know road
race or this walking thing or whatever
it's getting me back in touch with me
for 25 years I've had a head full of
ideas I've had half-assed projects and
lots of plans I chose always wishing
overdoing many of my blocks were due to
fear many just basic survival the idea
of goal setting it really fires me up
the idea of remembering to revisit those
goals that freaks me out if I just think
of all the things that I should have
done and want to do still but I again
I've thought about over the last 25
years what do you have a vision board
for that seems like what are you a child
let me tell you why vision boards can be
important with one huge caveat based on
science
vision boards are important
because when you take the time to create
a vision board which is basically
bringing your dream or your goal to Life
by creating a collage of images what
you're doing is you are grabbing that
dream or that goal that typically we
bounce around in the back of our minds
in private you're pulling it out of your
mind
and you are grounding it in reality and
one of the reasons why this can be so
powerful is because it signals to your
brain that this is really important to
you we've talked in previous episodes
about the zygarnic effect it creates
this kind of to-do list in your mind the
other reason why it's important is
because when you put a vision board in a
place where you can see it it keeps
these goals and dreams front and center
which is really important but here's the
problem
everybody puts the wrong on their vision
boards you've been sold a bill of goods
you have been told that if you simply
create a collage of some beach house or
your dream body or a million dollars in
the bank or a Maserati that suddenly the
universe is going to hand you those
things that's not how that works
what research shows is exactly what
Rochelle is talking about if all you
ever do is think about the big thing you
think about the end goal the beach house
the Maserati the thing that's like 10
years from now and then you create this
beautiful collage of this amazing thing
that you want that's a huge mistake
and see everybody makes this mistake if
you look at anybody's vision board you
know what's on it it's beach houses and
a million dollars in a Maserati and the
finishing line at the New York City
marathon and all the things that you
hope and dream for and the reason why
that's a huge mistake is that if the
only thing that is on your vision board
is the thing that's going to take you 10
years to get done as you sit here in
your studio apartment
or in the spare bedroom of your parents
house
at a desk in the corner and you stare at
a 10 million dollar beach house
oh my God
that is going to feel so far away
it's going to feel like
you might as well move to Mars for
crying out loud instead of that vision
board keeping your dreams front and
center that vision board is rubbing them
in your face it's not motivating at all
why because you start to become present
day in and day out to how far away you
are
from that dream of yours and that starts
to make you feel less motivated it
doesn't surprise me at all that Rochelle
has been thinking about all kinds of
things for 25 years and yet she can't
get started
and the reason why is because she is
making the mistake of visualizing the
end I believe that in some way your life
or the last three years
or the uncertainty that you have come
through
or the issues in your life that you have
survived have left the light switch on
your nervous system is in a state of
alert
that annoying light bulb was blinking
in the background
and it's time to turn it off
and so we're going to turn it off using
the vagus nerve
the vagus nerve runs from your seat
all the way through your body through
every major organ through your vocal
cords and all the way up to the top of
your head
and the technical term when you flip the
switch is your quote toning the vagus
nerve that's what researchers and
neuroscientists say I just say let's
just flip the switch let's just use the
vagus nerve and there's lots of ways
that you can do this
so the vagus nerve
when you hum hmm when you sing
I think one of the reasons why so many
of us love singing whether you're
singing in a religious ceremony or
you're singing with friends or you're
singing in the cars you're driving you
don't realize this but in addition to
just music's awesome is that when you
are singing you are flipping the switch
on the vagus nerve in your vocal cords
another way you can do this take a warm
bath
just go soak in a tub
it's amazing I love doing that
absolutely love doing that and another
way that you can do this you see this
all over the internet
cold exposure therapy
now I have a tub that I climb into I
hate it absolutely hate it but this has
been transformational because when you
put yourself in a situation
whether you're jumping into a lake or
you're sitting in a cold bathtub or
whatever standing in a cold shower just
end your shower with 30 seconds of cold
water it sucks
and what you're doing is you're exposing
your body to a situation where your
nervous system turns on the lights go on
baby when you climb into 34 degree water
and it freaks out and then you calm
yourself down by breathing and you are
training yourself
that even in situations where I get
triggered even in situations that are
awful like 34 degree water that I'm
sitting in
I have the power to flip this switch and
calm my ass down
breathe through it and know that I'm
going to be okay
that's a freaking superpower
and I know what you're thinking you're
like
are you showing me Mel Robbins
you're telling me to deal with trauma
by taking a freaking bath
you're telling me that I can handle
abuse from childhood and poverty and all
this crap that I've had to like deal
with my losing my spout and by taking a
Cold Shot what is wrong with you woman
yeah I am telling you that because
this is not about the shower this is not
about the bath this is about you and
your nervous system
this is about you training yourself
that you have the power
to be okay
no matter what's going on around you
that you are bigger than the things that
you survived
that yeah by standing in a shower you're
training yourself
for confidence for the capacity to just
to feel something and get triggered and
not let it hijack your life
that's what this is about and when you
do that you take that new you into your
life
you take a person who has the capacity
to have go sideways in your life
and not get hijacked by it
you become the kind of person that could
have survived horrendous trauma
and be able to
heal
yourself over time manifesting is
intentionally
training your brain and your nervous
system to believe in something that
hasn't happened yet
that's what manifesting is manifesting
is a power tool it's backed by
Neuroscience it is backed by years of
research and when used properly
it helps you achieve your goals because
it helps you prepare to do the work I
use
science-backed manifesting tools every
single day to shut down the negative
conversations in my life and to live a
big life and to take big risks and dude
Olympic athletes use manifesting and
we're going to get into how Olympic
athletes and the world's leading you
know Business Leaders and successful
people everywhere use it but I'm telling
you right now the way you shut down your
internal
conversation that is holding you back is
manifesting manifesting is one of the
first things you have to learn how to do
to get started on making this a reality
so what is manifesting manifesting is
mentally training
forgetting what you want that's all that
it is it is part of the toolkit that
successful people around the world use
let me tell you what manifesting is not
manifesting is not thinking thoughts and
then hoping they come through
that is what people do on their seventh
birthday and they blow out the candles
that is not what we are doing here
manifesting is based in neuroscience
it is a tool that you are going to use
precisely intentionally
systematically with purpose
because you use manifesting to re-wire
your mind and your body and your spirit
to help you do the work to achieve your
dreams
when you use manifesting properly
you are removing the mental obstacles of
self-doubt resistance fear perfectionism
feeling overwhelmed other people's
expectations all that stuff that is
holding you in place right now that
makes you spin in circles manifest and
clears that [__] out and it programs
using science a completely different way
of thinking and feeling about the things
that you want to create in your life and
when you manifest properly it's almost
like the pregame training that you do
before the big game It prepares you to
take action it boosts your confidence it
gets you ready to do that thing we all
procrastinate we avoid the things that
we know that we need to do and then we
spend the rest of the day beating
ourselves up it's amazing actually it
sucks doesn't it so how do you stop
procrastinating oh
simple just nail yourself to a chair
that's what you do you tell yourself no
booze until you get it done that works
no it doesn't the reason why these
things don't work is because most of us
don't even understand what
procrastination is I know I certainly
didn't
the reason why you procrastinate is not
why you think
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
procrastination is a stress reliever
that's right it's a tool that you use to
give yourself relief from stress that
you feel and the stress that you may be
feeling right now might be stressed
about money you might be stressed about
your health maybe you're stressed about
something going on at work or about a
relationship that you're in
and the way that this relates to
procrastination is you're stressed out
you got work you know you need to do but
instead of doing it you go online or you
watch the highlights of last night's
game or you waste an hour looking at
Facebook and when you do that when you
avoid work makes you feel good
but just for a minute
see this is where we get procrastination
all wrong a lot of people think
procrastination is about willpower it
means that you're lazy has nothing to do
with that it's all about your stress
that's why your work ethic or discipline
that's not that's not going to solve
this either the key to stopping
procrastination number one is
understanding what it is it's a way that
you deal with stress and number two it's
about five second decisions that stop
the cycle of procrastinating because
when you change your decisions you're
going to change everything and here's
how you're going to use the five second
rule to do it
when you catch yourself procrastinating
or you feel yourself starting to avoid
what you need to do
use the rule
54321 activate your prefrontal cortex
and then acknowledge acknowledge that
you feel stressed out that's the first
piece then you're going to use the five
second rule to just get started that's
it for five minutes that's all I'm
asking force yourself I'm stressed out I
get it but I'm going to work for five
minutes five four three two one sit down
and get started after you've worked for
five minutes give yourself a break watch
all the cat videos you want I don't
really care
the point here is that this is a way
that you can use the five second rule in
combination with research about beating
procrastination that puts you in control
of your decisions
Stacy found that when she used the five
second rule to improve her relationship
with herself there was an amazing result
she stopped procrastinating in her words
your rule has helped me grow in ways I
never thought possible I no longer
procrastinate on anything and the same
is going to be true for you because when
you understand that procrastination is
something that you do when you're
stressed and you also understand that
the secret to beating procrastination
which is a habit
is to just get started now you can use
the five second rule to leverage all the
research that will help you end the
habit of procrastinating once and for
all Neuroscience academic research and
other people's personal experiences can
provide unbelievable insights into how
when and why Behavior change efforts on
your part can succeed or fail
and I want you to have all of this and
be able to use it to your advantage I
already mentioned that 81 percent of
people give up on their goals well guess
what that's not going to be you because
you my friend are going to have the
science the tools the strategies the
shortcuts to not only making change
happen but making it stick and so this
awesome series that we are programming
and bringing to life for you is going to
begin today with the topic of goal
setting because one of the things that I
know based on the research is that no
change will last in your life if it's
not personally connected to you and no
goal will be achieved if you don't have
a connection to why you want to achieve
it and so I figured if we're going to do
a big series that's going to give you
the foundational aspect and most recent
research around changing your life we
better start with an episode where you
identify personal relevant and
achievable goals that you're excited
about
that way every single other episode that
you hear in this series for the next
month or so it's going to help you
achieve something that really matters to
you and the fact is goals matter
according to the research and you
probably have experienced this when you
have been working on goals goals matter
because number one they make you happier
number two they suppress negative
emotions and in fact based on some
groundbreaking research out of the
University of Wisconsin having goals
that you're working on can even suppress
feelings of fear and depression and
that's pretty cool
third goals give you a sense of purpose
meaning and being up to something in
fact I just had a conversation with our
daughter Sawyer who was saying that
she's kind of in a rut she's like I just
feel like my life is the same old same
old like every day is the same damn day
and it's only gotten worse because she
works remote and she's worked remote for
over a year and a half since she first
interned for the company she works for
as a senior in college she's almost
never gone into the office no holiday
parties no nothing in person every day
she sits at her desk at home and works
virtually she hangs out with her
roommate so she loves but it's like the
same thing in and out you want to know
what's going to fix this goals
because when you have goals it
interrupts the day-to-day doldrum it
gives you something to look forward to
it makes you feel like something cool is
happening and that leads me to the
fourth benefit life is harder when you
have no goals
based on the research having goals makes
your life feel easier and I think even
just that little story I just told you
about my daughter feeling like she's in
a rut you can see that when you're in a
rut
life is hard
when you feel stuck when things are
monotonous
it's hard
when you got something that excites you
something that you're working toward
that's pretty awesome
and that's why we you and me we are
going to start with your goals because
they matter
and what also matters is how you set
them
because if you don't set goals the right
way
based on science you fail before you
even start and that was Mel Robbins for
years how you can interrupt negative
thoughts and flip into a positive
mindset and why would you want to do
that well the reason why you want to do
that is because your thoughts Lead You
In a particular direction and if you
start to allow your mind to dwell on
negative outcomes if you start to obsess
that things are not going to work out if
you allow yourself to continue
to think negative thoughts you're not
only priming your mind to default to
negative but you will literally
through your thoughts trigger negative
actions you know if you think about it
you've had experiences in your life
right where you've really trashed
yourself you've hated on yourself and
when you continually think that you hate
yourself or you continually
tell yourself that you're screwing up
you tend to do things that you hate
don't you but when you're in a positive
mindset when you're in an optimistic
mindset when you interrupt those
negative thoughts and you start to say
well maybe it is going to work out or
you know I gotta just keep on going your
thoughts literally can trigger positive
action too anxiety
if this is the first time you're
thinking about it
anxiety is what happens when you are
worrying about something in the future
that makes you feel uncertain
or makes you feel like you're going to
lose control that's it
anxiety is when you you start worrying
about things in the future that make you
feel uncertain or make you feel like
you're about to lose control and you
start to get a stomach ache or you start
to feel tightness in your throat or you
start to shake your hands or you start
to have your heart race or you start to
have sweaty ponds your body starts to
get agitated because you're really busy
worrying about the test tomorrow you're
really busy worrying about whether or
not you're going to throw up you're
really busy worrying about that
sleepover and whether or not it's going
to go okay you're really busy worrying
about whether or not your friends are
going to talk to you when you walk into
school today or you're busy worrying
that something might happen to your
parents why did I give you those
examples there was a specific reason why
the top worries that kids 12 and under
have are number one throwing up now why
would throwing up cause kids anxiety
because as an adult you've probably done
it a bunch and so you know that you
throw up it's over it sucks but that's
it there's no sense getting yourself
worked up about it but for kids this is
the number one thing that kids are
afraid of because it is an enormous loss
of control when it happens and it scares
a lot of kids to have that happening to
them because their brains aren't matured
and they don't understand that it's just
a moment so they're not actually worried
about the throwing up
they're having anxiety because they're
thinking that it could happen at some
point and that makes their body feel
weird and then of course because their
body feels weird it makes them certain
that it's coming I mean kids can
actually I have a son that actually made
himself throw up because he got so
worked up thinking that he might
that he caused himself to this is a true
story absolutely true story so I have
lived this
um being worried about you dying major
cause of worry for kids they think about
it and if they think about it too much
and they don't have a process and a plan
around how to live with that very normal
fear it will turn into anxiety the
social pressures are being accepted
going to a sleepover and being worried
about what's going to happen because
you've never been to the house before
you don't really like dogs and they have
one your friend's dad kind of scares you
what time are we gonna go to bed you see
there's a lot of uncertainty that we
adults don't think about when it relates
to sleepovers at new friends houses that
your kids are worrying about and if they
stay up here and they start worrying
about all the uncertainty it's going to
cause their body to start to freak out
and then the whole thing starts to
spiral and next thing you don't they
don't want to go or they get there and
they're on edge and they need to come
home again we've had that situation in
our family too where the inability to
tolerate the uncertainty of something
that's supposed to be fun when am I
going to bed what are we going to eat
will I throw up on there are they going
to like me why are their parents like
what TV are we going to watch what time
are you picking me up in the morning all
of those unanswered questions and the
inability to tolerate the uncertainty of
that triggers the anxiety in your kids
this is what's happening in their brains
the rejection of you know that the group
dynamics of kids particularly in Middle
School brutal you couldn't pay me
millions of dollars to go back to Middle
School at this point but your kids are
walking into it every day and they're
worrying about whether or not they're
being accepted because every moment in
school is a moment of uncertainty about
whether or not you're going to get the
answer right whether or not people are
going to laugh whether or not you're
wearing the right things and so again
these are all the things that trigger
your child to worry because they are
racked with situations that cause
uncertainty and that make our kids feel
like they might lose control now here's
the major mistake that you and I make as
parents
when our kids start to worry or when our
kids start to feel anxious which is the
agitation in their body you know what
you and I immediately do we immediately
try to fix it we swoop right in and we
start to either say you're going to be
okay and we assure them because we're
trying to fix it right we're trying to
make the worry go away we say oh well
this is going to happen and that's going
to happen and this is going to happen
and so we answer all their Pro and we
start to put in all kinds of certainty
for them
and that is the exact opposite thing
that you and I should be doing
and it's it's our fault we've kind of
been doing it forever haven't we
stairs they don't fall down we've got
child locks uncapped so that they don't
eat anything we stop buying the Tide
Pods because we didn't want them to
choke on it like as parents were
constantly anticipating things that
could go wrong we're putting in controls
and so it is natural for you and me to
jump into Fix-It mode if you want to
get your kid
to move beyond the grip of anxiety you
have to understand how your behavior is
contributing to the anxiety itself
see one of the things that I believe
about anxiety is the reason why we
develop it
and the reason why we keep it around is
because it works I mean if your kid is
anxious and they start freaking out they
don't have to go to school so all of a
sudden that situation that they felt
uncomfortable around they've now gained
control because the anxiety worked you
swooped in you fixed it you said that's
okay you don't have to go
and the problem with doing this is that
we might be managing the momentary
breakdown
but we are not teaching our kids a
critical skill in life and that is the
ability the ability to tolerate not
knowing
and the ability in the face of not
knowing to assure yourself that no
matter what you'll figure it out that is
one of the most critical things that you
could teach your kids the self-reliance
the resiliency the courage and the
confidence to know that even though I
feel a little nervous and even though I
don't have all the answers I can trust
that I can figure it out and so that's
the kind of biggest picture that I want
you to switch your mind from thinking
you gotta fix this for your kids
and that's us buying into the anxiety
and realize that when anxiety is present
it means that your child my child can't
cope with uncertainty and now as a
parent it's my job to teach them how
when's the last time
you felt excited
because you're up to something that was
either cool or it was new or it was
exciting you know I think about times in
my life when I was up to something
it's like those moments of anticipation
I was applying to college or I was
applying to law school or I was making a
decision that I was going to leave a job
that I didn't like or even after a
breakup you know where you're newly
single and you feel like whoa oh I love
how many of you are saying right now
right now I feel like I'm up to
something
right now you know I feel like I could
be a part of something or maybe for many
of you who are saying I don't feel that
way Mel I'm feeling like my life is
pretty stagnant it was a long time ago I
can't remember when
I want to have you imagine something
imagine
how energizing and exciting it would be
to wake up every day and feel like
you're a part of something really cool
imagine if you made a decision
that starting literally today
you were going to be up to something you
were going to push yourself you know it
makes me kind of sad everybody how many
of you are sitting there saying
um I can't even remember I've lost my
direction and I want to tell you
something
if you feel lost if you feel stuck if
you feel like it has been way too long
since you've had something that you've
looked forward to
I
um I want to tell you something
Reserve to have that energy back in your
life you deserve to uh get the push that
you need because yet last night was a
reminder of something you know it's so
easy and I I know that I can fall into
this too it's so easy to kind of get
stuck in your rut especially after
working from home for two years
especially after coming through the
pandemic especially after being in this
routine of isolation and feeling like
nothing is ever going to change last
night for me being in New York City and
just coming down and being with friends
and seeing how energizing it is to be
around people that are up to something
it reminded me of this piece of research
that when you hear it it sounds kind of
stupid right but then when you stop and
think about it it's so true
when researchers study happiness you
want to know something crazy about happy
people
happy people
are just prioritizing and making time to
do the little things that make them
happy
and what we also know and you know this
too that when you look forward and you
see things in your calendar just this
weekend for example just this weekend
having something that you've planned
something that you're going to be a part
of that just having something just out
in the near future to look forward to it
gives you two bursts of energy too
number one the planning of it makes you
think about it right and as you
anticipate it and you anticipate what
something is going to be like
you get this burst of energy and then
the doing of it makes you feel energized
and excited again okay and so last night
when I came down here to New York City
to support my friend tune day and be a
part of her big event here in New York
launching her book just thinking about
the fact that it was coming up made me
feel excited and energized and being
there made me feel excited and energized
part of creating a better life is having
moments that you're going to have to
navigate where you get triggered by
something stupid or something profound
and all these emotions come up and you
say fit
and I do not want you to give up in
those moments I do not want you to throw
in the towel or throw out the Christmas
cards or say I can't do it I mean that's
what I did yesterday
I felt that huge wave I said that's it
it I came up into the office and I
started crying and I said to the team I
can't do this I can't talk about habits
I can't I can't even get Christmas cards
out in the mail I can't do this I went
to my husband and my daughter and I said
I'm not doing 75 hard I got too much
going on I this is not the time for me
to do this like I'm setting myself for
failure and you know what they said they
said yes you can
yes you can
and they sat there and they listened to
me wine and wine and wine and Chris
looked at me and he said Mel
you gotta have a breakthrough
you have to take on something that feels
hard and you have to do it for longer
than the month or the you know 45 days
that you've done it in the past
and right now is the perfect time the
fact that you're feeling the [__] it
just four days in this is a good thing
Mel because it's pushing buttons in you
and so
what was interesting
because it's pushing buttons in you and
you know what he's right
he's absolutely right and so I went to
bed
like immediately I didn't even want to
tempt myself because I was so frazzled I
went to bed I slept all night and when I
woke up this morning and came up to work
what was so interesting
is that life doesn't always
give you what you want
but it does give you what you need
and I think at moments sometimes are
what you need
because you need to see
that you can have a moment where you
want to give up
and you can even screw up in those
moments and you can get back on the
transformation train and you can keep
going
that you are bigger than the [__]
moment that the [__] moment is there
to test you it's there because it's part
of the process of growing and making
powerful change in your life
find the proof that you can do it
it's all around you you just need to
look for it
find anyone that has the life that you
want or that has made the change that
you want to make the relationship the
career the body the family the friend
group anytime you see someone who has
already made the change you want to make
in your life tell yourself there's proof
it exists use people as evidence that
yes you can have what you wish for too
if you're willing to work for it see
people as a light on the path to your
future self for years that was not me I
was the opposite I did not see other
people as lights on my path I saw people
as robbing me of the lights that I
wanted I had this really stingy jealous
and insecure attitude if a friend of
mine was renovating their kitchen I
would smile the tight smile that people
have when they're faking their smile and
I go oh it's so pretty I love the white
cabinets but inside I was seething with
jealousy and the reason why is because I
believed that somebody else's happiness
or success somehow was robbing me of
mine it's the opposite their beautiful
kitchen means if I can work for it I can
have one too they're amazing
relationships means I can create it too
their success or the business they've
built means it's possible for you too
this alone if you just do this third
step this one mindset flip it is a
complete Game Changer here's how you do
it there is unlimited success happiness
and fulfillment in the world
you're not in competition with anyone
the only one that can rob you of the
success happiness and fulfillment that
you deserve is you and your excuses and
fears and sitting around waiting to feel
motivated we're going to stop that today
correct good I'm glad you're listening
because we're not doing that anymore
you're not going to wait six years to
get started you are going to start
taking actions that align with what you
want now and when you see other people
as evidence of what's possible for you
as you start seeing them not as
extinguishing your light
but lighting the path that you're now
walking on holy cow talk about throwing
gasoline on that internal fire of yours
and by the way
don't you ever forget
you are a light on the path for someone
else
and you don't even realize it
so
think about that for a second
you are just a step or two ahead of
someone else
I mean if you've grieved the loss of a
loved one if you've changed your career
if you've survived heartache if you've
sold a family home if you've reinvented
some aspect of your life if you've lost
weight if you're able to live with
depression if you're the first in your
family to graduate from college your
life experience proves to someone else
that it's possible for them too so you
better make sure that as you start
chipping away at your own wishes and
goals that you hold that light up a
little bit higher for everybody that's
behind you when you have a limiting
belief
so that default Network in your mind is
programmed to think you're not enough or
the default Network in your mind is
programmed to think it never works out
for me or the default Network in your
mind is programmed to say
I'm never gonna make it
what happens with a limiting belief is
that you actively because of the default
Network in your brain is your brain is
actively filtering in and out
information
that agrees with the limiting belief
and so your whole mind is set up to view
the world and look for evidence that
you're not enough that things aren't
working out that you're never going to
make it
so there's a big difference between the
reality
that you're food compromised the reality
that you're unemployed the reality that
you're living with depression the
reality that you're divorced the reality
that uh you dropped out of school and
you want to go back and now study to
become a nurse those are harsh or can be
harsh realities it can be liberating
realities for some people not everybody
of course because those are very very
real and tough circumstances okay to be
food deprived I don't mean to say that
that's a liberating circumstance I meant
it from the dropping out going back to
school so let me be clear very harsh
reality to be food compromised very
harsh reality to be unemployed very
harsh reality to live with depression
very harsh reality to get dumped very
harsh reality to have a diagnosis that's
terrifying get it I totally get it
that is very different
than having the harsh reality be your
brain
and you've got a terrible diagnosis and
all your brain is doing is saying I'm
gonna die I'm never gonna survive this
my chances are
you got it so that you're making it
worse because of your default settings
um I want to train you regardless of the
harsh circumstances that you're living
in
that you get to choose how you view the
circumstances you get to choose how you
view the future you get to choose
whether or not you see nothing but
problems nothing but excuses nothing but
reasons to be depressed and sad and to
check out or whether you can train
yourself to still have hope to still get
up and try to still get up and be
positive to still get up and look for
opportunities to make your life just a
little bit better that's the difference
between harsh realities and your
limiting beliefs harsh realities are
temporary
you can change them
limiting beliefs will keep you stuck in
a permanent mental state because you are
continuing to look for evidence to make
negative beliefs true and that's why we
want to turn you into a deliberate
thinker the businesses that were
launched by somebody like you who was
working full time while launching your
business had a 33 percent less chance of
failing
than the people that quit their jobs and
jump all in
and the reason why is you know how to
hedge your bets you're a little
conservative in terms of the risks that
you'll take which means over the long
term your business is more likely to
succeed you asked me how do I balance my
passions how do you find the time
because I like you have a million things
going on from being an on-air
commentator to CNN to having an
incredible partnership with Success
magazine and doing a ton of cool stuff
with them to giving over 80 speeches a
year and running a company and having a
family
the key is this
you must find 30 minutes before 7 30 in
the morning 30 minutes before 7 30. that
you take at home that you take at a
coffee shop where you organize your day
and you work on two things that will
push your business forward
30 minutes before 7 30. why do you need
to do this well because when you walk
into work your day is likely going to
get hijacked and secondly if you were to
take this time every single morning and
focus yourself you're now starting your
day having already done work to advance
your business and you're walking into
your current job knowing what you need
to get done that's going to make you
work smarter at work I think a lot of
people that are working a job full-time
and also trying to launch a business on
the side actually have the time the
problem is that you're not being
rigorous and focused about what you're
spending it on what you're dealing with
when you have imposter syndrome is
you're dealing with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head that's saying you don't
deserve this this is luck how many of
you have that story this is locked this
is going to run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to literally destroy that
voice that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
boy that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experiences
growing up or Society at large has made
you feel either overtly or in a really
like gross and sort of Sly way like you
don't belong and so it is critical for
you to start to punch that voice
literally out of your head and I'm going
to give you some steps to do it okay
the second thing that's really important
is that in addition to stopping down
that voice because it's not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what I want you to understand is
that patterns repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has
that says you're not worthy you don't
deserve this luck is going to run out at
some point that you know what's going to
hit the fan again
brace
don't count on anything
like you didn't earn this if you got
that pattern running in your head that
is a broken pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so the Line in the Sand that I want
to draw starting today is you're not
allowed to listen to that garbage
anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there and I'm going
to teach you once you recognize that
pattern you're going to use this thing
that I created called the five second
rule you're going to count backwards
five four three two one because that
shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three two
one now notice when you counted did you
feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no I'm
just kidding
um
what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack
that interrupts all the garbage that's
here in the interior part of your brain
this is where imposter syndrome lives
everybody this is where anxiety is this
is where self-doubt is this is where
self-criticism is this is where it's all
stored when you notice oh there's that
voice again and you count backwards five
four three two one you shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the SATs
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no when you have
boundaries right this is the part of the
brain that gives you immediate control
over what you think and do next
and so that's a really important thing
number one you're going to notice it
number two
you're going to name it so let's give
that jerk in your brain a name so Heidi
what do you want to name this thing
um like close your eyes and think about
it everybody close your eyes and think
about like that voice that nasty stinky
awful skanky gross voice in your head I
want to kind of get an image in your
mind it can be a cartoon character it
could be a human being it could be like
some little pimply
ugly person from middle school that you
feel sorry for now
okay yeah because when you laugh at the
voice it doesn't have control over you
like it did right we want to make this
less serious so what's the name you're
going to give your voice well I was
thinking the voice but maybe something
like I don't know Rocky spiky spiky okay
what name do you want to give your voice
Linda Bob Bob okay how do you say your
name
sadanya great name what are you gonna
give your voice
maybe Peabody Peabody I got it I got it
okay how about you what's your voice
Bill Bill ooh conviction there's a human
being like that talking to you Bill we
are going to shut bill down okay what
about Isabella broccoli broccoli she
hates broccoli I love that that's great
how about you
Josh Josh okay great so whenever you
hear that voice what I'm teaching you is
to use the science of objectivity
to distance yourself from that voice
okay this is so important because you
are not that voice welcome in everybody
actually pull up your chairs closer Do
not sit that far away from me come on
yep let's go you're not late you are
right on time let's welcome them in okay
yep ladder clap ladder
foreign
super important everybody in life to
make people feel welcome
super important to invite people
especially other women
to have a seat at the table
and one of the things that I've learned
and then I'm going to catch you all up
on where we're at okay
one of the things I've learned is that
you know it's there's so much success to
go around
have you wrapped your brain around the
fact that there are what eight billion
people on this planet
there is so much success to go around
there's so much happiness
there's a tremendous amount of money to
make
there's a ton of people to date
and when you
focus on the fact that there is
Limitless possibilities for you
you're not in competition with anybody
in this room
and the louder you cheer for other
people
the more you invite people in
the more you will be invited in and the
more cheering there will be for you
it is incredible when you can flip your
mind from being jealous and competitive
and small-minded like if she's getting
that it means I don't oh no no no no no
if you see somebody getting something
that you want it's evidence that you can
have it too
you're just going to get it and have it
in your own way
and so you want to make it a habit to
cheer for and celebrate all the all the
women everybody you see around you
because their success means you can have
it too and trust me if you are a
talented hard-working kind person
a company will make room for you
they will find another job doing that
same thing
and so you focus on you you focus on
being the best you and I promise you all
the other people around you that are
having those things that you want
that's evidence you can have it too I
like to think of other people as a light
on the path I'm walking down
they're shining a light that helps me
walk in the direction of what I want
Angie why is it so easy to fill out
limiting beliefs but almost paralyzing
to figure out an alternative think this
not that how many of you are having
trouble with this it's very easy to see
where you doubt yourself but it's super
hard to come up with the alternative
thought that you're going to substitute
well the reason why it's hard is because
you actually believe these thoughts
and these thoughts have become patterns
and they've become habits and they've
become so uh prevalent in your life that
they're almost like the co-host
of your life
um you know if you think about it you
are the star of your life but if the
supporting actor is a limiting belief
that constantly tells you that you're
not good enough or that you're not
worthy or that you'll never succeed then
it's no wonder that you believe it
because the co-star of your life is your
limiting beliefs and so it's not
easy
to change your limiting beliefs but it
is simple
and it begins with you identifying them
and then substituting them so the most
uh I think effective way of beginning
the process of teaching yourself how to
identify a limiting belief and then come
up with your own
substitute positive belief as a way to
change the negative pattern in your mind
is to use the power of objectivity
so write down all your limiting beliefs
and I'm going to go through this in
detail in just a second write down all
your learning English I'm not worthy I'm
not good enough nothing works out for me
nobody's gonna love me whatever the [__]
it is that you think that's that's
bringing you down and then you can ask
yourself this what would Mel say
if Mal were sitting here across from me
what would Mel say
another thing you can do you can write
the opposite of what you're thinking
and you may not believe it it's okay
because what we're doing is training you
in a new pattern and one of the things
that Angie asked is she wanted to know
what were my limiting beliefs so
yesterday we sent out this workbook the
best decade ever toolkit it's in your
email if you go to the Facebook group
best decade ever with Mel Robbins it's
also listed on the files you'll find the
download for this check your junk email
if you didn't get it but
um so my limiting beliefs
so I want to have the number one talk
show of the decade
and the number one talk show of the
decade right now seems to be Ellen and
so it's interesting because a lot of my
limiting beliefs I think are provoked by
the fact that I'm the newcomer in a
space that I have huge dreams of making
a market and dominating so one of my
limiting belief is someone's already
done it how many of you have that one my
dream has already been done
so
my substitute thought because this feels
kind of true doesn't it
somebody's already done it
and then my
substitute thought the Think This Not
That is well they haven't done it my way
yet
it hasn't been done by me yet
do you see what I mean so somebody else
has done it okay I get it it hasn't been
done by me yet
it's it'll never happen
it'll never happen how many of you have
that limiting belief it'll never happen
my substitute belief it hasn't happened
yet
so I'm acknowledging that it hasn't
happened but I'm adding on the yet
as a way to keep my mind in the positive
uh it didn't happen last time so it's
not going to happen this time
how many of you have that one
yep this is what I say I wasn't ready
then
I'm ready now
you know because it didn't happen last
time because I didn't know everything I
know now I'm ready now
uh I don't deserve it how many of you
have this limiting belief I don't
deserve it
my thought is if I work hard I'll earn
it
do you see that so it flips from a
statement where I'm bashing my
self-worth I don't deserve it to a
statement about
putting in the effort if I work hard
I'll earn it
oh I've got this story that I'm the Bad
News Bears that I'm literally like the
person with the worst equipment and I'm
the underdog and I'm underfunded and
why does it have to be so hard and why
does it seem so much easier for
everybody else blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah and I flip that into I love
being underestimated and I love being
the underdog
in a very weird way as much as it
exhausts me it also empowers me
um oh here's a here's a specific
limiting belief
am I going to compete with
them I can't compete with Ellen
um
especially when she's been at it for 20
years she has uh the budget of God and
uh an army of people that are supporting
her I mean there was something she did
announced yesterday on social media that
I so like oh of course and I was so
jealous she announced a partnership with
Starbucks where she's encouraging people
to pay for somebody's coffee using the
Starbucks app behind them in line
um and then take a video of it and
upload it they're gonna bring him on the
show and I was like oh will I ever get
there will I ever get the good cool
stuff like that and the answer is yeah
she proves it's possible
and also I can take the 10 years and be
like and in 20 years
I won't even recognize the cool stuff
I'll be able to do if I put in the work
so take that jealousy or somebody else
or whatever and say it proves it's
possible now put in the work
um so those are some of my limiting
beliefs and that's how you can do it and
by the way if you can't do that exercise
successfully on your own Post in the
Facebook group and tell people this is
your limiting belief can somebody help
you come up with a substitute positive
belief so that you can think this not
that ask somebody in your life to help
you
um and then what you do is when you find
yourself going down the route of that
negative thought it'll never happen
you're gonna five four three two one use
the five second rule to interrupt the
negative belief and then you are going
to insert the positive belief it hasn't
happened yet that's it adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals Sim simply by
writing them down that's pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain that you deserve
to have these things you're signaling to
your brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off so that's step number one you're
going to start writing down five things
that you want every single morning as a
way to train your mind to let you dream
freely it's a message everybody needs to
hear because there's only one thing
I want you to do this week
nothing
do nothing
wait a minute
Mel Robbins
are you smoking something over there did
you just say do nothing
and here's the funny part about this
I bet you might be doing something right
now because you're a multi-tasker and so
am I you're listening to me while you're
doing the dishes while you're walking
the dogs heck you and I might be at the
point in our relationship where you are
actually sitting on the toilet and I'm
in the bathroom stall with you as you're
listening to this don't tell me that you
have not taken me into the bathroom
because I can even feel it over here
and I say this because we got to talk
about the art of doing nothing and look
I'm not stupid enough to think that you
can actually do nothing I mean obviously
not this is like a metaphorical
conversation because you probably have
to work I personally love working
between the week of Christmas and New
Year because nobody's there so you can
kind of like work half a day and you get
the full-time pay and it's way more
stress free and you can get more done
because you aren't in a million meetings
but if you do have the time off
let me guess
what are you doing with the time off
you're rearranging your cupboards you're
probably trying to learn Spanish you're
doing a million things on your to-do
list you are like just keeping busy
this week
just stop
please
I want to explain this concept this
metaphor of doing nothing
being able to do nothing whether it's
just for a minute
or it's for a day or it's for a week
this is so important and I'm having the
conversation not only with you I am
talking to myself right now too
I have a hard time doing nothing why
well because I'm just like you I'm
addicted to being busy I'm addicted to
my to-do list writing them out Crossing
them off throwing them away losing them
writing another one especially in the
world today
the world has glamorized being
productive being busy go go go hustles
hustle culture having a side hustle I
mean there's so much to hustle around
some days I literally have no idea what
I'm doing
you may always be on the go like I am
but are you actually getting anywhere
when life suddenly changes
and you feel like you have lost control
and you start to feel stuck and
Powerless how do you take control when
you don't know where your life or the
world or this moment is going
and here's the number one thing I want
you to know you don't need to know where
this moment or where the world is going
you just need to know where you are
going next and one of the things that
has happened uh certainly in the
pandemic but it always happens when
there's any kind of Reckoning in your
life
is that when you have something suddenly
happen and your life is fundamentally
changed whether it's a death or somebody
says I don't love you anymore or you're
fired or you find yourself with a scary
Health diagnosis there is a line in the
sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that Reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past I'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
Sudden Change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now in order to take control of
where you're going of what you're
thinking about and you can start to take
this moment of change and you can use it
to be able to take and make an
intentional pivot in the direction that
is meant for you next and one of the
things I want to say about this moment
is look if you're losing loved ones you
are terrified this has made you lose
your job you feel like you're in that
moment where everything you know you're
falling off a cliff you're trying to
pack a parachute you're grieving and so
you got to give yourself space to grieve
the losses that you're feeling
and when you get a little bit of
distance from The Grieving and the ways
of grief and fear that you're feeling
start to space out they don't ever leave
you but over time those waves of holy
cow and I don't want this and I can't
handle this and why is this happening to
me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again and you will absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing and I can
say that even though you may be facing
in a tough time because if you think
about your life you faced extraordinary
challenges and there hasn't been a
single one that hasn't made you a better
and stronger version of yourself and
this moment will be no different
so I want you to understand that when
you get out of the cycle of grief this
is an enormous Reckoning an enormous
opportunity for you to hit the pause
button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do I want my
life to look like
because I think too many of us are
sitting here going I can't wait for my
life to get back to normal I can't wait
for this to end I can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of Reckoning what happens is there's
actually parts of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what I've just learned based on
my old life when I look ahead to my new
life what is it that I want my new life
to look like this next chapter I can
turn to a blank page I can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and I can write something new
that's what I want you to know you don't
need to know where the world or where
everything is headed you just need to
know where you're gonna head next you're
not a procrastinator you have a habit of
procrastinating
big difference
because if it's a habit I can teach you
to use science to break it you see all
habits have three parts there's a
trigger and in the case of
procrastination the triggers always
stress
then there's a pattern you repeat and in
the case of procrastination it is to
avoid doing something and then there's a
reward you get a little stress relief
the only way to break a habit you guys
is not to deal with the triggers
you're never gonna get rid of the stress
in your life but you can 100 percent
change your pattern of avoiding work
so next time that you're in a situation
where you feel yourself hesitate you
spent way too much time checking out the
highlights from last night's scores what
you're going to do is you're going to go
up I must be stressed out about
something acknowledge the stress then go
five four three two one I want you to
count to yourself because I want you to
interrupt The Habit that's stored here
and I want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then I want you to just work just
for five minutes the reason why I want
you to only work for five minutes is
because your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding I just need
you to start and here's the other cool
thing
we know based on Research that if we can
get you to start 80 percent of you are
going to keep going everybody is capable
of change period you and I have seen too
much evidence of it that you could try
to argue to Tom and to Mel Robbins that
this person is beyond change it is
complete [__] I think everybody is
capable of change unless you have some
sort of incredible psychosis or diagnose
something or another that makes it
neurologically incapable
everybody's capable of change and so the
importance of what you're doing cannot
be understated because our brains are
organized to spot evidence that matches
our belief system that's the way the res
works and until you start to interrupt
the story that you're telling yourself
you're going to continue to feel stuck
you're going to continue to see those
thoughts and you're the kind of content
that you're putting out is hugely
important because the other thing that
interrupts the res is representation if
you see somebody that looks like you or
you see somebody like me that was facing
bankruptcy 14 years ago and have liens
on my house and you see somebody else
that face that you feel overcome by it's
proof that you can do it too the barrier
is everybody gives us what other people
are thinking yeah and so they're on
camera or they're on a microphone trying
to be smart or concerned about whether
or not they look good in the shot uh
concerned about uh how they sound
whether or not they stuttered if their
neck is turning red like whatever it may
be and they're so up here that they're
not actually being true to just saying
what's right here absolutely whether
you're speaking from the heart speaking
from the gut like that is the skill to
develop is the ability to be more like
an 11 year old that gets on camera and
can just be themselves instead of being
a 49 year old person censoring
themselves yeah it and that's what I'm
talking about when I talk about the
truth when I talk about authenticity
that people really want to feel that
connection and the only way that they're
going to feel that connection is if you
do the work to remove the own veneer and
the own barriers that you put in between
you and other people and the number one
thing is everybody gives too much about
what everybody else thinks and you know
who they think the most they're worried
the most about they're friends yeah if I
put this thing up not for my friends but
for the people that I'm trying to build
a rapport with online my friends are
going to judge me your friends
so friends if you're out to share
something that
friends don't like it or don't support
you they're really not your friends
absolutely
you know yeah
and it's a really hard lesson it's a
very hard lesson because everybody's
always judging everybody else that's why
you can't worry about it do you have
like recommendations for how people just
get started by from moving from that
like to basically move from their
mindset of I care too much to I don't
care as much like are there steps that
you recommend the only step that really
works is action because if you're
stopping to think yeah about what people
are thinking or whether or not you're
worried about what people are thinking
you've already fallen into the Trap the
second that you push yourself to get
started through the action itself you
are proving to yourself that even though
you care what everybody thinks you're
gonna do it anyway
and so that's why I talk about the five
second rule the five second rule is how
you interrupt the excuses the patterns
the concerns and the fears that you have
whether it's perfectionism whether it's
disappointing your parents whether it's
being judged by your friends whether
it's looking stupid when you post
something whether it's screwing up and
saying something that a bunch of trolls
come after you for right all those
things that everybody's concerned about
that can stop you forever if you go five
four three two one you break the part of
the brain where all of those trappings
are and you awaken your prefrontal
cortex which is the part of the brain
that you're using when you're creating
content when you're speaking with
courage when you're learning something
new and so that's why this simple brain
trick that I invented is exploding
around the world because every last one
of us is exactly the same exactly the
same you and I we want the same thing we
want to actually live
a life where we get to express ourselves
at the highest level we all want the day
the same thing and we're all stopping
ourselves the same way by thinking too
much by buying into the lies that
self-doubt tells you and so I'm here to
tell you you can cut that off at the
knees five four three two one you can
make a five second decision the second
you feel that doubt the second you feel
that concern the second you feel that
fruit that fear and you can literally
feel it and actually move anyway in fact
I was just talking with um my creative
director and she was sharing with me
that a friend of hers is going through
this terrible thing right now it's not
terrible it's just it's just what
happens in life where
um she knows that the relationship that
she's in isn't right
they get along really well things are
really easy but in her heart
she knows it just isn't right
those are the kinds of decisions that
are really difficult to make and so it
gets to the heart of Emily's question
which is how do I know whether to make a
decision with my head or a decision with
my heart I'm the kind of person that
believes you should always make
decisions with your heart and soul you
can use your brain for math you can use
your brain to look at the fine print in
a contract but when it comes to the
actual feel of the decision you always
want to go Inward and check it against
your heart and soul how do you do that
here's the simple test does the decision
that you're about to make expand you
expand your future or expand the
possibilities of your life if the answer
is yes then the decision is yes no
matter how terrifying it is
if you conversely look at the choice
that you have to make and the decision
will shrink you will silence you will
inhibit you in some way then the answer
is no no matter how easy the decision is
no matter how safe the decision is the
answer is no
now one of the things I want to point
out that when you start to use this does
it expand or does it shrink me does it
open possibilities or does it keep
things closed does it raise my voice or
does it silence me right
is that there's always a short-term and
a long-term impact to the decision
the short-term impact to making an
expansive decision a decision that's
based in your heart and your soul
sometimes it's terrifying because
sometimes it means moving or it means
changing a job or changing a
relationship or having a difficult
conversation or starting something new
and those sorts of things are always
uncomfortable so brace for impact put
the force fields up but make the
decision anyway because the long-term
impact of making a decision from your
heart and soul
that is where the
best life comes from because you're
living for what's true for you not
what's safe in the moment most of the
[__] that we react to is some sort of
response to a past experience
and that it's not until you have a
wake-up call from somebody like Tom
bilyu or you see somebody that has been
in your circumstance that has overcome
it or somebody says something that
challenges what's been programmed up
here that's the wake-up call and that's
when you realize oh wait a minute
all of this that I just naturally
believe like for example I didn't have I
did like you know I didn't choose to
speak English
that's what was spoken in my house so I
absorbed it if you grew up with a
hyper-critical parent or a narcissistic
leaning parent you probably absorbed
certain things from them that you don't
want now that you're an adult I won't
even say probably that's a guarantee yes
and so I just wanted to be very clear
because one of the things that prevents
people
from changing their lives is when you
said the thing about what's missing I
was going to say hope
because without hope
that things could change or that this
new action or thought matters you won't
do it
and so if you have this moment where you
immediately get this wake-up call that
maybe I don't have to be miserable maybe
I don't have to criticize myself maybe I
don't have to live with anxiety for the
rest of my life maybe I could be the
first one to go to college maybe I could
like live as an openly gay or trans
person even if my family rejects me like
there's that wake-up call moment that is
critical but now what you're up against
is completely learning how to reprogram
all that default that somebody else put
there and that's the work that you're up
to that's the work that I'm doing for
myself and I did it at a certain level
uh up until the last two years like I've
been shipping away at this at all
different kinds of levels and I think
the more self-aware you become
and the more successful that you become
and achieving goals or taking away a lot
of the stressors that you know are no
joke like paying your bills
the deeper the opportunity
to attack the deeper which is what I've
been working on if you want to get work
done you have to manage distractions and
interruptions so the tech stuff is easy
put your computer or your phone on do
not disturb so that you can get work
done that's number one
number two if it's interruptions from
family members
um
what the heck
put a sign on your door
do not disturb unless you are on fire or
uh I'll be available in an hour unless
it's an emergency
when we first started quarantining my
kids were so anxious and discombobulated
they would come in to my office at home
every 10 minutes mom how do I cook
microwave popcorn mom how much food do I
feed the dog mom
um uh is someone going to the grocery
store mom can I and you know what they
were doing
a lot of times when people interrupt you
they're managing their own anxiety
boredom procrastination by coming to
interrupt you
they're creating reasons to interrupt
their own work or their own emotional
state by coming and interrupting you
that's what I realized was happening
everybody was all discombobulated we're
underneath One Roof people are bored
frustrated procrastinating feeling
anxious and so what do you do if you
can't sit still and you don't want to do
what you're doing you get up and you
can't grab to a coffee shop and you
can't go run an errand and you can't go
do so you go interrupt somebody so I'm
not kidding when I tell you put a sign
on the door
the other thing that you should do that
is super helpful I know this sounds
terrible but it works like a charm on
Sunday night have a family meeting
go over the week outline all of the
things that you have coming up and then
you've got to take it a step further
I've been doing a tremendous number of
virtual presentations for companies all
over the world and whenever I'm
streaming online for a paid client
it's not enough to have previewed this
for my family on Sunday that takes care
of who's picking people up and what
needs to happen on Tuesday when I'm
giving the presentation but when I'm in
the middle of it nobody's going to
remember that Mom was not supposed to be
interrupted so you know what I do I text
everybody in our family group chat in
all caps I'm about to go online for a
paid client do not call me
do not I will not pick up from two
o'clock to 3 30. thank you I love you
and that is worked like a charm you
should hang something on the door and
you can have a sign that says you may
enter and then you should have a sign
that says you may not and then put a
sticky note as to when you're going to
be available again that way you are
training somebody to stop and think
before they walk in you're training
somebody to go is this actually
important before they come to you in
terms of everything else it's on you to
hit the Do Not Disturb it's on you to
send calls to voicemail it's on you to
turn off the notifications because you
simply can't work if those things are
happening you've got to manage the
interruptions and distractions period I
think most of us have an experience
especially as women where we feel and
know that we are last in our enlists
that if we tell somebody else we're
going to do something we will be there
but when we promise ourselves we're not
going to have a drink tonight or we're
going to get up tomorrow morning early
and journal or go for a walk or we're
gonna lose weight and stick to some
healthy goals because we know we deserve
to feel better we abandon those promises
over and over and over again
and one of the things that I've come to
learn about myself and that I've come to
learn about human behavior in general is
the reason why we women do that is
because we've been trained to
and we don't even need to go into it but
anybody that was raised uh in a
household in a traditional gender sense
who saw Behavior modeled for them around
being a good daughter or watching your
mom tirelessly take care of your
grandparents or her partner or her
friends watch her be exhausted you start
to learn that pattern yourself you start
to learn that people like you and they
love you more when you behave and when
you take care of them and so we do more
and more and more of it and there's
substantial research in every aspect of
a woman's life that this is true it's
also true in your job you probably are
the caretaker at work you bring in the
Cup dates for birthdays you're picking
up after the meetings and we're not
being asked to it's how we've been
trained to develop worth if somebody
else is happy with me then I can be
happy with myself as long as I'm not
disappointing somebody then I'm okay and
what I really had a breakthrough around
for myself and especially as a
businesswoman and learning how to create
better deals ask for my value learning
how to not feel guilty about going after
my dreams and how that might impact my
kids in some way
I had a huge breakthrough when I
realized that the foundation to success
and happiness and fulfillment begins
with your relationship with yourself
and for women in particular we have to
re it's not even retrain ourselves
because we were never taught how to put
ourselves first
we have to teach ourselves that it's not
only important it is crucial
that you learn how
to show up for yourself and so what does
that actually mean
what that means is that when you make a
promise as simple as a promise that says
I'm not going to have a glass of wine
tonight
that you develop the skill and you put
systems in place that support you in
keeping that promise
that when you say you're going to get
out of bed in the morning because you
know you feel much better if you take a
half an hour for yourself that you get
your ass out of bed in the morning why
because you said you would
and so when you develop
skills of keeping simple promises to
yourself what you're doing is you're
building a habit of putting your word
first you're putting a a you're putting
into practice via your behavior that
what you say to yourself in terms of
what you're promising that you would do
that it matters to you and you have to
do that because otherwise if we don't
learn how to do that for ourselves what
happens for most women is we get into
these issues with relationships where we
I don't know if you ever had this issue
but geez Louise it seems like every
relationship I had
until I met Chris and then this was even
an issue in the beginning of our
marriage I literally lost my identity
I would take on every musical taste food
taste I would get absorbed into my my uh
you know boyfriend's friend group I
became defined by whether or not I was
in a relationship to someone else
they came first their interest came
first and the biggest breakthrough in
your life and in your business will
happen when you learn how to have that
relationship with yourself right where
you learn how to put your needs first
and until you learn how to do that and
it's it's it's practiced by keeping the
little promises to yourself not drinking
the glass of wine if that's what you
said exercising or walking the dog if
that's what you said getting out of bed
when the alarm rings if that's what you
said you would do and most of us can't
even do that which is why we know we
can't count on ourselves to do the big
things there's a million paths to
getting what you want
you just have to find the confidence
to be able to start and to say this is
what I'm doing
it doesn't matter if it takes a year 10
years 20 years this is what I'm doing
and I'll tell you another reason to do
it
your kids learn
by your example not by your words
and so if you want your daughters and
your sons or your kids that identify in
any range of the spectrum
to pursue their dreams and be themselves
you have to show them what that looks
like
and so if mom is taking a Thursday night
to go to an online course you are
demonstrating what it looks like to
prioritize time for your dreams you're
demonstrating what it looks like to have
values that align with your actions and
that will seep into the pores of your
children I think about life as one long
road trip
your past right now is behind you it's
in the rear view mirror and the future
it's right out that windshield that's
why the windshield is bigger than the
rearview mirror because we're not going
backwards people we're not doing that to
ourselves we are going ahead and you
know what's in front of you an Open Road
every single birthday I believe is a
mile marker on this road trip called
life it's a chance to pull over for a
second and think about the open road
ahead where do you want to go next how
fast you want to go how slow who do you
want to have in the car with you there's
endless metaphors around this and it
helps me think about this major topic of
reinvention and change now I love
birthdays I'm sure you do too and I love
them for so many reasons because every
time you're celebrating a birthday I
mean think about what you're actually
celebrating
we're celebrating the fact that you're
still here we're celebrating your
existence that you're breathing that
you're alive how cool is that and you
want to know what else we're celebrating
when we celebrate your birthday
we're celebrating the possibility and
Magic
that your life and the future and that
next year holds for you
now there's one part of celebrating your
birthday
that I want you to really think about
okay
you know that moment when the cake comes
out
your mom or your dad or your spouse or
your friends or the waiter they bring
out that cake and the candles are
burning on top and everyone starts
singing happy birthday to you
and then they put the cake down
you look at the candles you close your
eyes
and you make a wish
and for just a moment
time stops
have you ever noticed
that as that cake gets closer to you
and you start going inside and thinking
about the wish that you're going to make
you don't even hear anybody singing
anymore
you hear something inside yourself
you hear something deep from within
you close your eyes you grab that wish
and you blow out those candles as if
it's going to magically make that wish
come true
and when you open your eyes you're
present to the wish
you feel excited for the year and you
can almost see all the new possibility
that you could tap into in the year
ahead
well researchers have a name for this
exact moment it's called The Fresh Start
effect
when you make that birthday wish you
break from your past self
and this transformational window of time
opens up
you think bigger you feel hopeful and
inspired and there's some incredibly
interesting research that explains why
these moments are so powerful
I'm looking right now at a study from
the Wharton School of Business at the
University of Pennsylvania where they've
studied the intrinsic motivational power
of this Fresh Start effect
researchers studied moments in our life
where we feel motivated to make big
changes and birthdays are an example of
that it's as if a birthday hands you a
blank slate a clean page a fresh start
at a whole new year and this feeling
inside you ignites an intrinsic
motivational aspirational Force that's
hardwired within you it's this power to
change you're not going to feel
motivated or inspired to do the work
if you're bashing yourself and saying I
need to lose weight
but if you say no I deserve to be happy
and I know this is going to make a
difference you are building the skill
of self-empowerment
you see it's a skill to push yourself
through the resistance that you're going
to feel
when you have to create a new habit it's
a skill to tune out the self-doubt and
to push yourself and do it anyway it is
a skill to listen to a more positive
voice in your head and tune out the
negative one that you've been listening
to for 20 years and so instead of
thinking in terms of habits and all
these kind of patterns of behavior I
want you to think about the fact that
what habits create in your life is they
create skills and self-awareness is a
skill pushing yourself to take action
when you're afraid or or not feeling
like it that's a skill
being kind to yourself that's a skill
and when you have something as a skill
in your life you can use that skill to
help you in every area of your life if
you want to go from thinking about it
and wishing about it you're gonna have
to push yourself to take action because
nobody's coming to build that dream
fight the fights you need to fight to
push through the excuses that you have
it's up to you
because if you want to create a better
life
you're gonna have to work for it you're
gonna have to prove it you deserve to do
it but no one is coming to do it for you
and the second you Embrace that that
it's your responsibility because it's
your life
it's your responsibility because those
are your dreams it's your responsibility
because this is what is calling to you
and the good news is this once you have
the clarity and the courage
to say I'm interested in being a food
blogger I'm interested in losing weight
I'm interested in launching a podcast
which is my new project
you can reverse engineer anything I mean
if Terry and I can figure out how to
build a digital brand I think you can
too uh and there's something called
Google and there are books and there are
workshops you can take the information
is out there it's your attitude
that is keeping you stuck getting the
little things right is everything
so getting out of bed moving your body
checking your attitude before you walk
into your business so you don't bring
any negativity in with you the way that
you greet your spouse and your kids when
you walk in the door at the end of the
day the stuff you put in your mouth
the person that you listen to in your
head
get out of here Tina right
you focus on all those little things all
day long everybody
and the big things take care of
themselves
you know how to do this and so we want
to make it more complicated than it is
everybody it's not
when you get the little things right
every day it shows your brain and your
nervous system your mind body and spirit
that you care about yourself
it shows you that you can rely on
yourself and it creates its own form of
momentum and I see a lot of you crying
and I know why because you're not
actually getting the little things right
you've given up on yourself because
you've gotten so focused on everybody
else and taking care of everybody all
these big problems and we have to bring
it back to the basics and so what I
would have told myself when things
started to feel scary
is I would have said you got to get out
of bed
you gotta like stop barking about what
Chris is doing and you gotta cheer for
the man
you got to stop griping in your mind and
letting your own negative Voice come in
and you gotta fight
to get the little things right we've
been getting a ton of questions about
being paralyzed with the fear of what
other people think and this is so
commonplace I think every human being on
the planet is is paralyzed in some
aspect or some area of their life
because they're concerned about what
their parents or what their friends or
what their friends on Facebook or with
their colleagues or what their upline or
their downline or whatever what their
neighbors are going to think if you are
struggling with this and you have not
found it helpful to attack your thinking
patterns then here's a trick that I want
you to try to break the pattern of being
paralyzed by what other people think I
want you to pick one thing one thing
that you've been wanting to do that
you've been thinking about but you have
stopped yourself from doing because
you're concerned about what other people
think let me give you some examples
maybe you've wanted to go on a wellness
retreat but you think your spouse Will
Roll their eyes at you so you haven't
done it maybe you have a particular
Facebook post or blog so many of you
want to start a business or start
creating art but you're terrified of
putting yourself out there because of
what other people will think today we're
going to break that pattern what you're
going to do is you're going to pick one
thing you've been stopping yourself from
doing and you're going to do it you're
going to do it and the reason why I want
you to do this is because I know that if
you're still paralyzed you have not been
able to change your thinking patterns
yet that's cool no problem we're going
to try a different tactic I want you to
change this paralysis through action
because if you sign up for that class if
you go on that Retreat if you create
your art if you post that blog post if
you start that business you will be
proving to yourself through the actions
that you're taking that you don't care
what other people think try that today
let me know number one what you've
stopped yourself from doing and number
two what you're committing to doing
today because one way to break this is
to attack the thoughts and change the
thoughts and get into action first the
other way to do it is to recognize that
you're paralyzed pick one thing that
you're gonna do and actually get it done
and you gotta view this moment like a
test and what is the test testing it's
testing Who You Are
that's part of the race right now how
you show up for it right it's not a
matter of how you finish it it's how you
show up for it and what you do while
you're running it the kind of racer that
you are and look I get it this is a very
difficult race that we're all running
because we don't know where the finish
line is and it is very very hard to stay
motivated which is the advice that
you're seeking Peter when you don't even
know when this damn thing is ending this
is the part of the race I've run four
marathons don't everybody gasp I mean it
was nothing to uh to brag about I mean I
finished them which is which is
something to brag about but it's not
like I won the damn thing but this is
the point in time when you're running a
race when you said you're losing ground
what that means is you're starting to
slow down you feel your legs getting
heavier you feel your breath getting a
little bit more shallow you start to
wonder oh why did I sign up for this
thing in the first place you start to
wonder if you are going to make it and
so here's what I'm going to tell you
Peter when you are coaching your clients
and your clients start to lose ground
when you are coaching your clients and
your clients don't feel motivated and
they feel tired and they feel like
giving up and they don't want to do
another set of burpees what do you tell
them you tell them to dig deeper you
tell them to find the strength within
them to keep going you see what you need
right now is you need to start building
the motivation of your mind because
motivation doesn't exist in your body it
comes from up here and what I hear is
that you now have an opportunity this is
what the test is Peter to train harder
because you are capable of so much more
this is handing you a moment
where you get to become an even stronger
and more capable version of yourself now
does that mean that you're going to be
motivated all day long
uh every single day that you wake up no
but it means you've got to have the
mental Fitness right now to continue to
get up
to show up and to dig deeper when it
comes to your mindset when it comes to
your attitude when it comes to your
just knowing
that you are going to get through this
and so this moment everybody it's
telling you who you are
it's telling you whether or not you're
the kind of person that shows up to a
challenge and you're pissed off or
you're sad or you feel depressed or you
feel despair or you feel all of these
things that start to take you down the
drain of negativity and what I'm here to
tell you is that you are built for this
moment you may not feel like it you may
feel sad those are all normal feelings
you may feel negative it's very easy to
do you may start to feel a little bit of
Despair that's going to come and go but
this is where the test of this race that
we're currently running Lies when those
feelings rise up and you start losing
ground and you start feeling like you're
not going to make it to the finish line
and you start feeling unmotivated can
you dig deeper and remind yourself that
you were built for this moment because
one of the things that I know is that
when the is hitting the fan I guarantee
you there are people in your life that
are looking to you there are people in
your life whether it's clients or
colleagues or family members that are
looking to you right now you know what
that tells me that you're the kind of
person that people rely on and now is
the moment in time in the race that
we're all running where you got to teach
yourself to rely on yourself how do you
do that how do you build the muscle of
the Mind
it's very simple
very simple I didn't say easy I said
simple the steps are very simple
to win
this race
and to build strength in this muscle
right up here
you got to focus on this you can control
and that is what you do with your body
and what you do with your mind
and the one thing that has made a huge
difference in me because you can see
that I am showing up as a very different
Mel Robbins than I've been the last
couple weeks the last couple weeks I
have been losing the race I've been
going up and down I've been doing my
best to stay positive but I am now back
in the race I have now found my ground
and found my footing and it comes in
focusing on what you can control and you
know what you can control there's only
one thing
it's what are you doing to make this day
the best day that you can do what are
you doing to master this day to day
tomorrow forget about next week forget
about what's happening this summer this
is a race that will be won by those of
you
who are the ability to focus on today
and making today amazing I want to teach
you how to train yourself to dream big
it's actually a skill and dreaming big
is something that we used to do as kids
right it was so easy as kids to sit in
class because you were bored with you
know whatever it was that your teacher
was doing and you started the Daydream
and as adults we tend to lose that
ability so the dream book is going to be
your companion to this program and
here's my philosophy about training
yourself to dream big again as an adult
in the dream book one of the things that
you're going to be doing as a daily
practice is you're going to do something
that I do in my book and that is every
time I crack this open because I keep my
notes in here is I write down the five
things that I dream about so I've
written down okay am super
super embarrassed that I've written this
down so I'm gonna tell you what my five
are and you can see you probably can't
see how red I'm turning because I have
so much makeup on because I was on in
television today and in television they
put a lot of makeup on you and digital I
normally look like [__] but this is why
we all need to learn to dream big and to
dream authentically because when you
talk about it you immediately shrink
because we're trained not to have these
aspirations so the first thing that I
wrote down is I want to be the number
one talk show in the United States you
know what's so fascinating is I used to
dream of just actually being where I am
and now that I've achieved that I have a
dream that's even bigger and what does
it mean and why is this dream important
to me and this is part of what you're
going to learn in the workbook but I'll
tell you why the stream is important to
me because if we are number one it means
that the work that we're doing that I
care so deeply about which is helping
people heal their minds and heal their
relationships and to live a more
positive happy mentally well life that
we're reaching more people that's what
that means and that's why I want it I
wrote down number one New York Times
bestseller I have for years said I don't
give a [__] about it but I actually do I
guess and I think it's because it would
be really nice
to have the powers that be actually
acknowledge the impact that we're making
do I need it to keep going forward no of
course not and I will keep going forward
I want to make the time 100 list for
mental health and for the work that
we're doing and the reason why is
because as much as I like being an
entrepreneur that does things in a very
Innovative way that kind of public
recognition brings with it resources and
partners that would allow you to make an
even bigger impact and so when I think
about that kind of recognition it
challenges me to dream so much bigger
than I'm Dreaming right now about the
impact that I want to make in mental
health the fourth one this is not my
dream right now but I wrote this down
three days ago and that is to be the
happiest I've ever been living in
Vermont
the reason why I wrote that down at the
time is because my son is going to go to
high school in Vermont and we are
grappling with a move and I had a mental
breakdown when we started looking at
houses there thinking I couldn't live
here one of the interesting things about
dreaming is your dreams will change I
love the daily practice of writing in
your dream book the five things you're
dreaming about because you'll notice
that there are things that show up
consistently for you and that's a sign
that it's important to pay attention to
it it's important to walk toward it and
by writing I dream that I'd be the
happiest I'd ever be in Vermont I was
doing the work of trying to shift my
attitude about how I was feeling about a
move when I'm not that excited about it
right now the fifth one is I want to
build a summer house I grew up on Lake
Michigan I've spent the last 30 years
not on the water I dream to be
successful enough that someday in the
next decade I will have the money to buy
a fantastic piece of property on the
ocean and I will build an awesome house
that is a gathering place for our family
and hopefully that will not include
grandchildren in the next decade I'm
going to be talking to you about the
connection
between worrying
and anxiety
and how it is critical if you want to
quiet your anxiety
if you want to stop worrying if you want
to get control over what you're thinking
about it's going to begin with a habit
that you have that somebody else trained
you that you've gotten really good at
this habit and you know what the Habit
is it's the habit of worrying we all do
it we're all guilty of it we're all
um guilty of sorry let me just move that
a little bit we're all guilty of
worrying about things that are beyond
our control worrying about things that
doesn't matter worrying about things
that we shouldn't care about sorry I've
got the streaming lights uh anymore hold
on let me just ask Mandy a question
um worrying about all kinds of things
that you shouldn't worry about and it
becomes a habit it becomes a default way
of thinking and so in order to kick off
anxiety week I want to explain
um the connection between
um worrying
and why that impacts anxiety and now
since we're talking about anxiety I have
to be very clear about something okay I
am not a therapist
I am a individual who struggled
personally with anxiety for more than
two decades I took Zoloft which was a
lifesaver and I strongly believe in
trying medication when a professional
believes that you are so in a hole
mentally that medication will give you
the ability to start to claw your way
out of that hole
um I have learned so much about anxiety
because of my own struggles and five
years ago I trained myself to be a
deliberate thinker just like I'm
training you to be a deliberate thinker
in this program and through everything
that I am about to teach you and all of
the
um all of the the strategies that you're
about to learn
I learned all of these by researching
anxiety and I Road tested them on myself
while I was still in therapy and I then
started going off of my medication and
as my mindset reset and as my thinking
patterns became more positive and
stronger and healthier I was able to
completely cure myself of anxiety and I
say that with the utmost of relief and
confidence and I have also used gone on
to use these exact same techniques that
I'm going to teach you to help my
children deal with their anxieties I've
written extensively about anxiety in the
five second rule book which is right
behind me we've sold almost a million
copies of that book it is the number one
self-published audiobook in the history
of audible I'm so proud of it and I
speak at length about anxiety and using
the five second rule to cure yourself
of anxiety okay but I need to make it
very clear that these training sessions
are in no way no way a substitute for
getting professional help if you have
the kind of clinical
anxiety or you suffer from an anxiety
disorder it is Paramount that you seek
professional help from a therapist
one-on-one that you try remarkable
um therapies uh I'm gonna say it wrong
but it's uh e d RM or erdm which is the
rapid eye movement therapy incredibly
helpful and so don't be a hero don't go
off your meds cold don't quit therapy
because you think that this live
training program is the answer this live
training program is a step and this live
training program for the next week in
particular while we talk about anxiety
you're going to be introduced to tools
that are grounded in research and tools
that have worked for millions of people
and tools that you can take back to your
therapist or take back to whatever
counseling you get to help you become a
deliberate thinker which will help you
quiet your anxiety get control of it and
then ultimately cure it with the help of
a professional if you have an anxiety
Disorder so
uh said
please please please listen to
everything that I'm about to tell you
and try it okay
please try it because this stuff works
if you practice it and again quieting
anxiety it's not an event it's not a one
and done this is a process that you are
going to repeat over and over and over
again because the connection between
anxiety
and your mindset
begins with your habit of worrying
we have a question from Twitter is
worrying the same as overthinking if
you're overthinking about positive stuff
and keeping yourself in an excited state
no it's not if you're overthinking and
the overthinking is you spinning
scenarios in your mind that are negative
yes
overthinking is another word when it's
negative for worrying on overdrive it
means that you worry in loops and you
keep repeating the worry over and over
and over as if you were washing the same
load of laundry over and over and over
again and so we're starting with the
habit of worrying worrying about things
that don't matter
worrying about things that you can't
control worrying about things that
haven't happened yet
worrying about things that are far off
in the future
when you start to train yourself to
think about things
that are not in your control
or think about things that are
statistically likely never to happen
that is when you can get into trouble
and that's why we're going to start with
worrying you see worrying
is when you allow your mind to default
on autopilot and think about things that
don't serve you
think about things that are outside of
your control here's another massive
Insight so I always think about
businesses levels right and I also
realize that as the media landscape or
the
um the particular vertical or industry
that you're building a business in is
changing that is a constant and it's
something that you can't control right
you just cannot control the things that
are happening in the world around us but
you can always control what you're
thinking and what you're doing in
response to it so all of my work Centers
inside this gap between what's happening
in your life and in your work and what
your reaction is to it and how you can't
control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control what your
reaction is and that Gap there that's
about five seconds long and you start to
understand that you can change how you
think you can change your habits you can
change how you lead you can pivot and
change even the philosophy of your
company and you can do it through the
decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions you will become
Unstoppable so three years three and a
half years ago I got into the speaking
business
um because of the popularity of that
tedx talk that I gave and
um that first year I did
um I don't know I think was like 27
speeches the next year I did 87 last
year I did 121 I was the most book
female speaker in the world this year
I've capped it at 80 and here's why I
realized just like you may be realizing
in your business whatever your business
is that there are aspects of your
business that you love and that energize
you and there are aspects of your
business that are depleting as hell and
that are old and that are tired and that
if you continue in that lane you're
going to end up 10 years from now in a
place that you don't want to be it's so
important for you to pay attention to
what's energizing you about the
landscape around you and about your own
business because that's the secret to
seeing around corners and so the corner
that I was seeing around is that as an
entrepreneur even though it's wildly
lucrative to do what I do just on the
speaking platform I mean anybody can do
the math on 121 speeches right and the
amount of money that I get paid to show
up and deliver a one-hour talk and
realize there's a lot of money here's
the problem it's a terrible business
because you can't scale it other than
raising your price or raising the number
of of times you do it and guess what
else you have to show up
and I can't sell it so I found myself in
a situation where I had built a
multi-million dollar business highly
profitable and it was depleting the hell
out of me and I can't really scale it
and I can't sell it terrible position to
be in in an entrepreneur so I made a
decision that I you know what was it
Beau that actually energizes me about my
business and I answered it with the
first question it's hearing from people
I would rather answer comments on
Instagram all day long than stand in a
stadium with 5 000 people in it I get
more from the one to one connection
that's what fuels me and so I had this
light bulb moment paying attention being
clear that wait a minute I don't want to
build
the biggest speaking platform and I
don't want to build a coaching business
I want to build a Content company I want
to go back to my roots and build a media
company and so with that Insight I now
have to change right because the kind of
business woman that runs a
multi-multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your travel folks and your Logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than then the
kind of leader that is going to grow a
hundred million dollar Media company
that's going to Syndicate content every
single day that is going to own what
she's doing that's going to build
Instagram and Facebook and YouTube and
Linkedin as my personal ABC CNBC Fox and
this is what I want you to understand
about the story and that is this in
order to get to the next level in your
business you got to decide right now
what habits do you have as a leader that
you have to change now because you will
not see around the corner you will not
engineer that next Quantum Leap unless
you personally change and so one of the
reasons why I've gone from being the
most successful female you know book
speaker on the speaking circuit to
launching the number one book on all of
the self-publishing platform for Amazon
and one of the most read books in the
world and selling like gang investors
still is because I am constantly
innovating myself
I know that I am the single biggest
problem in my company
and if I don't constantly pivot and
evolve how I lead and what I'm focused
on I'm gonna be the blockade and so you
know stop looking at what everybody else
is doing stop micromanaging the team and
ask yourself two years from now when you
think about where you want your company
to be what habit do you have to change
right now the thing about
procrastination
is it's triggered by stress so you're
cleaning
is being triggered by stress and there's
only one way to deal with this pattern
you have to interrupt it so when you
catch yourself cleaning next time that's
a moment of power because you're you're
now present you're like oh my God here I
am cleaning again use the five second
rule five four three two one two switch
gears in your brain and get control in
the moment and then I want you to just
do one thing on your side hustle that's
it drop the cleaning stuff walk over
send one email on your side hustle write
one paragraph of content do one thing
and here's why here's why I want you to
focus on doing one thing or working for
five minutes that's it set a timer for
five minutes I'm gonna work on content
for five minutes we know based on the
research that your eighty percent eighty
percent of the time you're gonna keep
going past the five minutes because the
issue isn't that you don't know how to
create content the issue is that when
you start to feel stressed out
you go to cleaning it's a pattern that
you've trained yourself to do the only
way to interrupt that pattern is to
break it and insert a new one okay and
let me just say something about uh
procrastination and perfectionism okay
because how many of you struggle with
being a perfectionist yeah yep I'm sure
um
the thing about those of you who are
perfectionists
is that um it is it's not about being
perfect
perfectionism is really your attempt to
be in control
and we're seeing a massive rise in the
number of people that struggle with
perfectionism and I think it has to do
with the fact that our culture is now so
focused on performing from an early
childhood from how you doing school to
being on the right club team and then
it's the travel team and then it's the
this team and then it's recruiting for
college and the way that we parent our
kids and helicoptering and swooping down
and and the pressure of college and the
pressure to achieve and the the concern
that you're going to make a mistake I
mean this has become a
self-imposed epidemic and so if you are
somebody who struggles with
perfectionism you can't turn in
something at work until it's perfect you
can't finish the paper until it's
perfect you can't even start with
redecorating your room until you know
the perfect color that this is really
about control you are uncomfortable
just being in the flow you're
uncomfortable with the unknown and the
most important thing here is to realize
that this is a pattern
and you absolutely have to break free of
the need to do everything right
and to get into the mode of just being
willing to try
get into the mode of understanding hey
if I turn in something at work that's
not like perfect I'll get feedback and
then I'll make it right like in the work
and in the willingness to just keep
pushing things down the line keep
showing up keep raising your hand even
though you're not sure you're gonna say
it right keep contributing keep asking
for feedback you a thousand percent
will slowly lose the grip of being a
perfectionist because the only way to
break that pattern is to realize oh my
God I'm trying to keep control and
that's why I'm holding on to this paper
that's why I'm torturing myself that's
why I'm doing everything
the magic is in the willingness to push
things forward to try to get in the flow
to basically say I'm either gonna I'm
just gonna do my best that's it I'm not
gonna do it
do it until just try I'm gonna do my
best and when I get feedback on how I
can do it better that's how I'm Gonna
Learn
uh you know I am a lifelong learner I
don't ever think I'm gonna do anything
perfect
um I
this is not something I struggle with
anymore because I have broken this
pattern in my mind and realized that all
of the all of the opportunity and Magic
comes from you being willing to put
yourself out there when you're not
perfect being willing to do things and
start things when you haven't figured it
out and understanding that when you get
into the flow and into the conversation
and into the live stream that you can
get into problem solving mode and you
can figure it out you
set and having
a full mindset and being deliberate
about what you're going to think about
and what you're not going to think about
it begins the moment you wake up and
believe it or not how you wake up not
when but how you wake up and the first
few things that you do in the morning
will dictate your mood for the rest of
the day which based on science is going
to impact your productivity and it's
going to impact how you feel about your
life and it will also impact
your mindset for the rest of the day and
that's why now that we've done in days
one two three four and five we've done
foundational training you've learned a
tremendous amount about how your brain
works about your default Network about
how to be a deliberate thinker you've
spotted your limiting beliefs you've
learned how to think this not that
you've started the skill and the
practice of the skill remember it's a
process not an event to be a positive
thinker you've started practicing
catching your limiting beliefs and
swapping from that default way of
viewing the world and thinking about
yourself and choosing deliberate
thoughts now let's talk about physical
habits that you can adopt that are very
simple that will be life-changing
because they will impact your ability to
be in control of what you're thinking
and to be deliberate and that begins
with how you wake up so let me talk
about the morning
you can think about your morning routine
and whether or not you even have one in
the exact same way that we think about
the brain you're either defaulting to
something that you've always done that
may not no longer serve you or you're
getting deliberate and choosing to do
something that's more positive and
Powerful because you deserve it and that
starts with your morning routine so if
you're the kind of person where the
alarm goes off and you hit the snooze
and then the alarm goes off again and
you hit the snooze and you know
eventually you roll out of bed and you
step into your day and you maybe drink a
big dark cup of coffee and you skip
breakfast and you skip exercise and
you're tired if that's how you start
your day
your mindset is going to be impacted by
that if your alarm goes off and you
immediately reach for your phone and you
start scrolling through Instagram while
you're in bed and looking at Facebook
and you are putting all kinds of stuff
in your brain that triggers fomo that
triggers insecurity that triggers
anxiety that is going to impact your
mindset for the rest of the day and so
starting tonight I want you to take
control and be more deliberate about
your habits in the morning and what
we're going to do this week is we are
going to build based on science the most
powerful morning routine that you could
possibly have sorry I'm just moving this
around so that the Instagram channel is
brighter the most powerful morning
routine that you could possibly have
based on science it's super simple it
will help you become a more deliberate
and positive thinker and I'm going to
walk you through step by step and you're
going to be doing this with more than
230 000 people around around the world
so what is the assignment tonight the
assignment tonight is very simple
and you're gonna hate it
you're totally able to do this
and most of you are not going to you're
going to let your limiting beliefs and
your default mode of thinking stop you
from making this simple change and the
thing that I want you to do tonight this
is your assignment
this Smartphone right here
I don't want it anywhere near your
bedroom your assignment is when you go
to bed tonight you are to plug your
smartphone in
outside of your bedroom if you live in a
studio apartment put it on the other
side of the room
I don't want this phone anywhere near
where you sleep
and there's a simple reason why
you're addicted to it and if it's next
to you while you're sleeping
as soon as you wake up
without even thinking the default mode
of your brain will mindlessly reach for
this and you will lie in bed and you
will look at your phone
and when you do that you are putting in
garbage into your brain before you even
get out of bed if you wake up anxious if
you wake up overwhelmed if you wake up
feeling like you're losing some
imaginary race if you wake up and you
feel dread if you wake up and feel
negative or exhausted I'm telling you
this is the reason why
and if you want to have a positive
mindset this year and you deserve to
then you also have to get very
deliberate about your habits and about
your morning routine in particular
because how you wake up matters how you
wake up determines your mood how you
wake up determines on your phone hold on
IG is pausing a lot hold on a second
let's see here
um yikes all right hold on a second IG
uh
I'm getting a lot of uh let's get on
Wi-Fi
Rendezvous let's see if that works
looks like I'm on
let's go back to Instagram okay let's
see if that works is that better Mandy
um
thank you for your patience by the way
normally our streams are not as spotty
but when we started this program I knew
that I was going to be traveling 24 out
of the 35 days that we're broadcasting
live and Tech can be a challenge and so
for those of you that have been hanging
in there on Instagram if it's spotty
jump over to Facebook live jump over to
YouTube jump over to Twitter we're
streaming on all four platforms at once
and we will also email you a link to
this video which is one of the reasons
why if you haven't yet sign up for
melrobbins.com mindset reset because we
curate all this information for you and
we tee it up for you every day
um so thank you for your patience as I
am broadcasting from uh my parents place
my mother's 70th birthday is tomorrow
and
um for those of you that are just tuning
in because the stream has been dicey
we're talking about the powerful
connection between your mindset and your
morning routine in fact I would say it's
not even powerful it's critical
you cannot have a positive in control
mindset if you don't have control of
your mornings the barrier is everybody
gives
what other people are thinking yeah and
so they're on camera or they're on a
microphone trying to be smart or
concerned about whether or not they look
good in the shot uh concerned about uh
how they sound whether or not they
started if their neck is turning red
like whatever it may be and they're so
up here that they're not actually being
true to just saying what's right here
absolutely whether you're speaking from
the heart speaking from the gut like
that is the skill to develop is the
ability to be more like an 11 year old
that gets on camera and can just be
themselves instead of being a 49 year
old person censoring themselves
and that's what I'm talking about when I
talk about the truth when I talk about
authenticity that people really want to
feel that connection and the only way
that they're going to feel that
connection is if you do the work to
remove the own veneer and the own
barriers that you put in between you and
other people and the number one thing is
everybody gives too much about what
everybody else thinks and you know who
they think the they're the worried the
most right they're friends
if I put this thing up not for my
friends but for the people that I'm
trying to build a rapport with online my
friends are going to judge me your
friends seriously if you're out to make
a difference if you're out to share
something that is important to you if
your friends don't like it or don't
support you they're really not your
friends absolutely
you know yeah and it's a really hard
lesson it's a very hard lesson because
everybody's always judging everybody
else that's why you can't worry about it
yeah recommendations for how
people started like
basically moved from their mindset of I
care too much to I don't care as much
like are there steps that you recommend
people the only step that really works
is action
because if you're stopping to think yeah
about what people are thinking or
whether or not you're worried about what
people are thinking you've already
fallen into the Trap okay the second
that you push yourself to get started
through the action itself you are
proving to yourself that even though you
care what everybody thinks you're gonna
do it anyway
and so that's why I talk about the five
second rule the five second rule is how
you interrupt the excuses the patterns
the concerns and the fears that you have
whether it's perfectionism whether it's
disappointing your parents whether it's
being judged by your friends whether
it's looking stupid when you post
something whether it's screwing up and
saying something that a bunch of trolls
come after you for right all those
things that everybody's concerned about
that can stop you forever if you go five
four three two one you break the part of
the brain where all of those trappings
are and you awaken your prefrontal
cortex which is the part of the brain
that you're using when you're creating
content when you're speaking with
courage when you're learning something
new and so that's why this simple brain
trick that I invented is exploding
around the world because every last one
of us is exactly the same exactly the
same you and I we want the same thing we
want to actually live
a life where we get to express ourselves
at the highest level
we're all want the day the same thing
and we're all stopping ourselves the
same way
thinking too much
by buying into the lies that self-doubt
tells you and so I'm here to tell you
you can cut that off at the knees 54321
you can make a five second decision the
second you feel that doubt the second
you feel that concern the second you
feel that fruit that fear and you can
literally feel it and actually move
anyway you shouldn't feel alone because
so many people have anxiety about toxic
relationships related to their families
and how they have to confront them
during the holidays so here's the thing
I want you to think about when it comes
to the holidays holidays can be one of
two things when you have toxic
relationships with your family it can
either be a personal challenge or it can
be a chance to have a personal
transformation and the personal
transformation that I'm talking about is
not changing your mother or your
annoying older brother or your racist
Aunt I'm talking about whether or not
you have a personal transformation
because you can't fully get rid of toxic
situations or toxic people but you can
transform how you behave when you're
around those kinds of people so the
holidays can be a chance for you to
practice boundaries practice
self-control to be emotionally resilient
and strong and not get triggered and to
also have the courage to express the new
you to express your true self so if you
left home a long time ago you've grown
as a person you've changed you've
evolved and then every time you go back
home you feel like you've stepped into a
Time Warp and you're suddenly eight
years old again this is a chance to
transform yourself so that when you walk
in the door you are who you are now not
who you used to be when you still lived
at home and so there's a couple things
that I want you to think about before
you go home before you have the
interaction so that you are prepared
emotionally to make this a
transformation for yourself personally
number one don't assume the old role
that you used to play so just because
you're in your childhood home or you're
with people that you know from your
childhood do not make the mistake of
falling back into Old patterns don't
suddenly start acting like the youngest
one again if you're the youngest in your
family if you'd always been dad's
favorite and everybody hates that stop
playing into it so there are things that
we do that we don't even realize when we
step into our childhood homes or around
the people that we grew up with where we
slip right back into Old patterns make
sure you know what those are so that you
have them in check for yourself number
two this is a huge one don't take the
bait this was advice that I got from my
brother a long time ago don't take the
bait you know that there are relatives
and friends from your past that just
love to cast The Guilt they just love to
cause issues they're constantly casting
like a fisherman all kinds of things out
there and if you're the kind of person
like I used to be when somebody gets
upset you grab the bait and then you
start trying to make it okay and the
next thing you know you're arguing with
somebody over something really stupid
just don't take it don't let yourself
get triggered is somebody's cast in The
Guilt let them cast don't hit that lure
you know what I'm saying they're welcome
to say whatever they want to say if you
don't react there's no issue you don't
have to worry about making sure that
your mom or your dad doesn't say that
stuff just don't react to it and you'll
be shocked at how the dynamic changes
you know this is another piece of advice
that my friend Danielle gave me today
and it comes from the com app you can
also before you go into the situation
visualize it's a really busy road now in
a very busy road there are people that
are passengers in those cars and there
are people that are pedestrians on the
sidewalk who are watching the cars go by
I want you to think about the dynamic in
your family as cars zipping down the
highway right everybody's got all kinds
of issues and conversations and kids and
this and that and people want attention
and there's all kinds of things racing
by your role when you're around your
family is to be a pedestrian on the
sidewalk watching it all go by this is
another form of not taking the bait the
last thing you want to do when your mom
pulls the guilt train up is to climb on
board and be a passenger on that ride
okay you know what I'm saying you're
going to stay on the sidewalk you're not
going to take the bait you're just going
to watch the traffic as it speeds and
whips by don't climb in when the guilt
car pulls up okay next thing this has
also been a major thing for me empathy
empathy is a superpower my relationship
with my mom changed dramatically for the
better when I stopped judging her and I
started thinking about what she must be
feeling seriously like if you've got
somebody in your life that's angry that
says hurtful things that's disappointed
or upset all of those things anger pain
disappointment it's all just a mask for
Hurt So any kind of toxic behavior that
you're seeing in other people unless
it's some sort of narcissism personality
disorder for most normal human beings if
they're exhibiting bad behavior it's
literally just unexpressed hurt that's
all that it is and a healthy dose of
empathy like thinking about how hard it
was in the household where your parents
grew up or thinking about all the
struggles that maybe one of your
siblings who's really annoying because
they take up all the energy how many
struggles they've faced or thinking
about how lonely your aunt is because
your uncles died thinking from a point
of view that's empathetic it's amazing
it's very personally transforming
because it helps you set boundaries it
helps you not get triggered it helps you
to be more emotionally mature and
resilient and it will help you make
these holidays an opportunity for
personal transformation instead of a
massive personal challenge the two forms
of anxiety
are over functioning and under
functioning
now neither one is better or worse
they're just patterns
and the cool thing with patterns
is once you can spot them and talk about
them
and you understand them and unpack them
you can start to create mindfulness and
a little bit of distance between the
things that trigger your anxiety and
that coping mechanism kicking in
because for me when I get into the mode
of doo doo doo plan plan plan I got it I
got it I got it
I drive myself into the ground
I burn out
and that's exactly what happened this
weekend
six weeks
of basically going into hyper drive mode
as a way to cope with all this
uncertainty
led me to crash
because I'm terrible at asking for help
and my husband
I'll have to ask him how he copes with
his anxiety because he has a really
amazing way of staying calm so over
functioning anxiety
is doo doo doo
it's ah giving advice instead of asking
for help it's assuming responsibility
for things that aren't necessarily your
responsibility it's managing everybody
else's emotions and I am the master at
this
and
the other form of anxiety is
underperforming and as I was thinking
about this
one of my three kids has this form and I
never would have
thought it given their personality
underperforming is when instead of
thinking through your issues you start
asking for tons of advice
you push the responsibility to other
people to solve your issues you
withdrawal you become paralyzed
and
the reason why it's important
to really think about what kind of
anxiety you have and what I want you to
do is in the comments I want you to
write down
are you a over functioning over
performing anxiety person or you are a
under functioning underperforming
and
what happens
when you are over functioning is I Rob
the people around me
of
supporting me of being responsible for
themselves of helping out
I Rob myself of the support that I need
and deserve
and
if you stay in the pattern too long
of either under or over functioning
you will drive yourself into the ground
again you've got to express these
emotions
because burying them has never worked in
the history of time
and so what I want you to do is again
write in the comments
what is your pattern
when you feel anxious do you over
function or under function
and the solution
today is very simple
I just want you to recognize the pattern
and for you over functioners
when you recognize yourself going into
that mode
take a pause
get into your body
ask yourself
what do I need help with
and who can I ask for help and what am I
taking on that I don't need to take on
and how can I get myself into this
moment and ground yourself
and if you are an under functioner
same thing
recognize when you're spinning
and asking for advice or overthinking or
paralyzed
instead of
problem solving and getting into action
when your life blows up
and you find yourself in the ocean with
like pieces of the boat all around look
for a life preserver or a raft okay so I
want to applaud you for doing what
needed to be done
when the you know what hit the fan
that same instinct is what is going to
make you successful
the second thing that I want to tell you
is once you get a hold of that life raft
you want to grab something else that
floats right and get yourself out of
that water and so I am glad to hear that
you're looking for a job
and what I would recommend is I would
recommend not pretending
about the situation that you're in
there is no shame in going to a job
interview and at the end of it saying
and I'm asking you for this job and the
reason why I'm asking you for this job
is not only because I am going to be
incredible at it and you're never going
to regret it but I actually need it
I'm in a really tight Jam
I had a life crisis happen I never
thought at the age of 55 I'd be in this
situation and I need the work and I want
the work which means I'm going to show
up here every single day
and I am going to work the heck out of
this job
I've never wanted a job more than I want
a job right now
and you should tell your friends that
this is what you're going through and
that you need help and that you need a
recommendation or you need a place to
stay
and you should not do what I did which
was hide what was going on because I was
so ashamed
and you know I'm also going to tell you
it will take time five years ago I still
had the liens on this house
five years ago guys
and so it will take time
for you to climb out of this but you
will climb out of this
when you're in a storm
and when the lights go out in your life
and things feel really dark and really
heavy
there has always been one thing that
helps me get through those moments and
it's reminding myself that this moment
like every painful moment of my life
was temporary
it passed
and when you can keep telling yourself
this moment is it's gonna pass and it's
it's it's leading me somewhere when you
can trust in that
you create your own light in that dark
tunnel
and it allows you to look up and one of
the things about
learning something new like how to make
money online is that it acts like a
beacon for where you're freaking going
yeah
it's not going to be
the power boat that gets you there right
now I know you know what I mean because
you need to find another freaking life
jacket which yeah you get a job I know
you need to like just keep going on
these interviews and there's no need
like if you've gone on all these
interviews and people are like you're
amazing and then you don't get it you
think it's because you're too old you're
too desperate they say you're concerned
there's no shame in writing back and
saying I'm not sure if you filled the
position
but I didn't mention that I actually
need a job right my pride got in the way
and so if you haven't filled that
position or maybe you uh are looking for
more peer people I want to make sure you
know I'm not looking to be a consultant
I've never wanted to find a great job
more than ever Than This Moment there's
no shame in that what's the worst
they're going to say yeah we filled the
job I guarantee you that right now you
are not even allowing yourself to fully
dream or think about or set goals that
are truly aligned with what you deeply
want in your heart that you aren't even
able to manifest properly because you're
not even honest with yourself about what
you actually want this is a really
common thing because you're allowing
your self-doubt you are allowing your
fears your anxiety your insecurity
you're allowing where you are to dictate
and limit where you want to go and so
step one super important you must allow
yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system I write about the RAS
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit the
RAS is a filter in your mind and you can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do in
order to teach yourself how to dream
with the lid off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliberate action and you write
down what you want you are signaling to
your brain that you deserve to have
these things you're signaling to your
brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off what is your limiting belief what is
the thing that you think about yourself
maybe your parents or your mother or
your father taught you to think that way
about yourself maybe you went through
horrible breakup and that person made
you feel unworthy maybe you've had a
bunch of uh setbacks in your life and
that's what gave you that limiting
belief but what is your limiting belief
because today what we're going to do
today is we're going to take it a step
further now that you've identified your
limiting belief we're going to look at
what is it costing you to choose to
repeat it because remember the quote I
started with you can you have a choice
right now you get to repeat the things
you've always done or you can evolve
them and become more deliberate let's
talk about the cost of that limiting
belief I'm gonna go first
so write down your limiting belief I see
a lot of I'm not good enough my mental
health is holding me back I can't run a
successful business I'm lazy and I can't
do anything I'm not healthy enough money
is the issue I'm scared to fail what is
the limiting belief that you have I I'm
certain it has something to do with not
being enough
once you've written that down you're
afraid of failure you're not you don't
deserve success all that kind of stuff I
don't know how to start these are
excellent you're doing an excellent job
the first step to moving from that
default into getting deliberate is
actually seeing it so seeing it is
fantastic because now we can start to
understand that whoa this got programmed
in it's my default mode I want to get
rid of it how do we get rid of it well
let's first identify why you want to
let's take a hard look at the cost the
cost of having this limiting belief so
in order to figure out the cost of
having the limiting belief what's my
limiting belief that I'm not a good
person
that's my limiting belief
that I am not a good person that you
don't think I'm a good person that I
don't think I'm a good person
um and here's what you're going to do in
order to identify the cost okay you're
going to ask yourself three questions
and they're very simple
what is this limiting belief in my case
that I'm not a good person what does it
cost me in my past to think this way
what is it costing me in this present
moment to think that I'm not a good
person
and here's the kicker
if I don't evolve this if I don't get
deliberate what is it going to cost me
in the future to continue to think that
I'm not a good person
so in the past
thinking that I'm not a good person
it did a bunch of things first of all it
made me very sad
secondly it made me a liar because I
assumed that I wasn't good enough and
I'm not a good person so I got to
pretend to be somebody else
it also made me cheat on people because
I didn't think I deserve love and it
also by believing that I wasn't a good
person it somehow Justified the bad
behavior I mean if I'm a bad person then
I do bad things right
what does it cost me in the present to
believe that I'm not a good person well
it cost me a lot of Joy it cost me
connection and friendships because I'm
constantly questioning whether or not
people actually like me for me
um it makes me second guess myself and
whether or not I deserve the success and
what does it cost me in the future it's
going to cost me everything if I
continue to repeat this pattern
and I continue to allow myself to
default to believing that I'm not a good
person
I will
never be fully happy I will never be
fully present I probably will not be
successful when we launch this new
daytime talk show in the fall
um and so I got a choice to make and I
want to get rid of this because I can
see what allowing myself to believe that
I'm not a good person is costing me this
exercise of of identifying your limiting
belief and then seeing what it's cost
you in your past your present and your
future is so important for you to do not
only do I want you to close your eyes
and picture yourself going back to the
dorm room notice I'm closing my eyes
it's because
manifesting is a habit for me and when
I'm manifest I get in it man I close my
eyes I go into my mind I am literally in
my imagination there and I not only can
see myself doing the work I can feel it
you can feel what it's like to walk into
that dorm you can feel what it's like to
sit down you can feel the heavy backpack
hit the table you can feel yourself
crack open that book you can feel
yourself sitting at that desk in the
desk light and you can also even feel
what it's like can't you as the Sun
starts to set and it gets darker outside
and the light and your desk starts to
get brighter and take things over you
can just put yourself right there and
the feeling is super important because
again manifesting is mind-body Spirit we
got to get your nervous system involved
we've got to make you feel like you're
at the scene one of the reasons why
feeling it is so important is because it
magnifies the imagery in your mind
and when your mind rehearses something
here's what's cool about your brain your
brain doesn't know the difference
between you studying for that test
are you doing the work to
start that business or get healthy or
put yourself back out there or heal your
trauma or save the money to get that
house that you want or whatever it is
that you're visualizing your brain
doesn't know the difference between you
visualizing those things
and you actually doing them in your mind
it's the same so it's almost like a
training run for a marathon you are
building a muscle that helps you win
when you take the actions it's so cool
and so you not only want to feel what
it's like to study for that test put
yourself at the scene you also want to
feel a sense of Pride that you're doing
the work and the pride piece is really
important because the pride piece acts
almost like a booster it amplifies the
memory imprint when you like bring this
WOW there I am I'm doing the work I'm
proud of myself I'm staying in I'm
putting in the extra work somebody said
no and I kept on going I didn't stop
when the first Venture Capital firm said
they wouldn't invest there I am
investing again when you feel this sense
of pride in yourself it supersizes the
imprint and the rehearsing and so it's a
super important part of the feeling not
only feel the steps feel the pride that
you're doing it this is so important
that I want to give you yet another
example let's say that your bucket list
something on your bucket list is to run
a marathon for me it was on my bucket
list when I was a young mom to run the
New York City marathon now what's
interesting is I applied I got a number
and when I won this number out of a
lottery system with the New York City
marathon I was a brand new mom I was
totally out of shape I was not at all in
any kind of of a place to run the New
York City marathon now here's the thing
I used visualization to help me
lower my fear and my excuses because
when I got the number I did not have a
lot of time if I had been a person who
was not visualizing I probably would
have said uh I don't have enough time to
train I'm not ready I can't do this all
the excuses would have come in but
instead I used visualization now how do
you use visualization for say a marathon
you do not want to visualize crossing
the finish line that is how you
visualize incorrectly
luckily I knew how to visualize at this
moment in my life you need to visualize
yourself going from zero
to preparing to run that race so what
does that mean that means you need to
visualize oh there I am it's five
o'clock in the morning oh I don't feel
like getting up but I'm getting up and
I'm putting on my sneakers and it's dark
out and I don't feel like going for a
run but there I am going out the door
alone in the cold wow I am going for I'm
I'm pretty proud of myself because I'm
training oh here's another thing you
could visualize I'm on a training run
it's Mile seven and it starts to rain
and I keep going
wow I'm wet and I'm still running I'm
proud of myself because I'm out there
training it's mile 11 and my earbuds
just lost battery
I don't have any more music
I got five more miles to go I'm out here
for almost another hour and I continue
going and I continue going and I see
myself completing that 16 mile training
run and I allow myself to not only feel
what it feels like to push through that
moment when those earbuds run out of
battery
but I also feel proud of myself for
pushing through that's how you prepare
yourself
for the thing that you need to do
because it removes the obstacles that
would stop you from pushing through what
is it that you want to create
or change in your life okay I want you
to write something down it could be
something tiny that there's like a
specific thing that you want to change a
specific habit or it could be something
really big and it's important that we
start there because I want you to have
the thing that you want in mind as I'm
talking okay what is it that you want to
create in 2022 wealth stability you want
to stop
procrastinating right you want to create
Independence you want to feel like
you're aligned you want to uh get your
education you want to change your
exercise and eating habits you don't
want to be a passenger in somebody
else's life anymore you want to be The
Driver of your own life that's fantastic
and as I talk and as I teach I want you
to continue to think about this goal
that you have to think about this change
that you want to make okay and what
we're going to talk a lot about today
is we're going to talk about this
principle
that I believe
and the principle is this
profound personal and professional
change starts with you
that's right profound personal and
professional change starts with you
and change starts with you because the
most effective change starts from the
inside out okay and so as you think
about a behavior change or a thinking
pattern change that you want to make or
some sort of goal or dream I want you to
take everything that I'm about to teach
you
and have that example in mind okay so
that everything that I'm talking about
isn't just stuff I'm doing in my life
isn't just stuff that you read about uh
when you look at the research in terms
of habits and manifesting but you
actually walk away with take away that
is specific to what you want to achieve
the reason why habits are so important
everybody
is because based on uh research this is
from a study that was published uh a
couple years ago that 40 of your
behavior are what we call Habits
habits
that's just another word for patterns
okay and so I'm going to give you some
examples
of habits that you might not even think
about are a habit okay
and a pattern or a habit is simply
a behavior pattern we call them a loop
and I'm going to explain why
it's a behavior pattern
that is stored in the subconscious part
of the brain you'll also often hear
people talk about the basal ganglia and
the reason why you have habits is
because your brain loves shortcuts see
everything that your brain is doing and
your nervous system is doing we've
talked a lot about this in other
trainings but everything that your brain
and your nervous system is doing it
requires fuel just like your car
requires fuel for you to be able to go
from where you are right now to the
grocery store that's how it runs your
brain requires fuel
and your brain has figured out ways to
maximize
the fuel and to be more efficient
and the way that your brain is more
efficient is it learns habits and
patterns
and when you have a habit or a pattern
that you have memorized because you've
repeated it so many times it takes less
fuel for your brain to reflexively do
that pattern than doing something new
and I'll give you an example
um this is something you can test out
later today or tomorrow
I want you to think about like a place
that you often bike or drive to maybe
it's a grocery store maybe it's work
maybe it's school maybe it's friends
house
tomorrow I want you to consciously drive
an entirely new and different and longer
way and you will notice something you
will notice that your brain fights you
you will notice that your brain is
annoyed and you will notice that it
takes more effort for you to think about
where you're headed
because the way that you commute to work
or school or the grocery store you have
repeated that so many times it is now a
pattern or a habit Loop stored in your
brain that's why often you get to places
you always drive and you're like oh my
God who drove the car because you don't
remember driving the car because your
brain was in the background making
decisions that have already been
automated so the reason why that happens
just in summary is because if you had to
use your prefrontal cortex and focus on
every aspect and every decision from how
you pick up the toothbrush to how you
hold a pencil to all that stuff you
literally would need to take a you'd
need to take a nap by one o'clock in the
afternoon you wouldn't be able to
process that much new information
and so it's a way for your brain to take
a break it learns patterns automates
behaviors so let me give you some
examples of some habits you might not
think about
picture yourself
sitting at the wheel of a car
and you put the car in Reverse which
shoulder do you look over as you're
backing up
it's always the same one isn't it and
depending upon where you live in the
world it's one side of the other
it's always the same you don't even
think about it do you
that right there is a habit
that is a reflexive action and pattern
that you do without even thinking
now think about your evening routine do
you lock the door every night
at home
do you have a pattern or habit of things
that you just go through in your house
reflect you don't even think about it
right
you're not like oh it's time to lock the
door about where is the door I can't
remember how to do I better Fortune no
you just get up you walk to click the
lock and it's just a pattern that you do
that is triggered by the end of the
night
here's the second thing I want you to
know about patterns
patterns repeat
if you don't
interrupt a pattern
and replaced it with something else the
pattern will repeat forever
so learning new behaviors and learning
new habits
is a lot more
about spotting the things that you don't
want to do anymore
and interrupting them
and then replacing those old patterns
with new patterns
and I believe that when you start to
feel broken or stuck in your life
you're not broken you have a pattern
from your past that makes you feel
broken based on where you want to go now
and I also believe that when you feel
stuck in life you're not actually stuck
you're just stuck repeating these old
patterns and until you catch them
and you interrupt them which is where
the five second rule comes in there's
nothing more powerful to help you
interrupt an old pattern than counting
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt the loop but then you have to
replace it with something else
because if you don't replace the pattern
what's rule number one about patterns
patterns repeat
so you can't just break a habit
technically you don't break a habit
technically you replace it with
something else one of the things that
has happened uh certainly in the
pandemic but it always happens when
there's any kind of Reckoning in your
life
is that when you have something suddenly
happen and your life is fundamentally
changed whether it's a death or somebody
says I don't love you anymore or you're
fired or you find yourself with a scary
Health diagnosis there is a line in the
sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that Reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past I'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
Sudden Change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now in order to take control of
where you're going of what you're
thinking about and you can start to take
this moment of change and you can use it
to be able to take and make an
intentional pivot in the direction that
is meant for you next and one of the
things I want to say about this moment
is look if you're losing loved ones you
are terrified this has made you lose
your job you feel like you're in that
moment where everything you know you're
falling off a cliff you're trying to
pack a parachute you're grieving and so
you got to give yourself space to grieve
the losses that you're feeling and when
you get a little bit of distance from
The Grieving and the ways of grief and
fear that you're feeling start to space
out they don't ever leave you but over
time those waves of holy cow and I don't
want this and I can't handle this and
why is this happening to me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again and you will absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing and I can
say that even though you may be facing
in a tough time because if you think
about your life you faced extraordinary
challenges and there hasn't been a
single one that hasn't made you a better
and stronger version of yourself and
this moment will be no different
so I want you to understand that when
you get out of the cycle of grief this
is an enormous Reckoning an enormous
opportunity for you to hit the pause
button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do I want my
life to look like
because I think too many of us are
sitting here going I can't wait for my
life to get back to normal I can't wait
for this to end I can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of Reckoning what happens is there's
actually parts of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what I've just learned based on
my old life when I look ahead to my new
life what is it that I want my new life
to look like this next chapter I can
turn to a blank page I can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and I can write something new
that's what I want you to know you don't
need to know where the world or where
everything is headed you just need to
know where you're gonna head next
I used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries I mean not a
nothing zilch nothing in fact there were
periods of my life where it was worse
than zero because I was so attached in
romantic relationships that I literally
would become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally if it's possible to have
negative boundaries meaning you like
somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as uh emotionally
attached in relationships and as people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify
communicate and uphold boundaries in my
life you can learn how to do this too
okay and so that's what we're gonna
unpack in this video so I think a big
question because a lot of people talk
about boundaries they know they need
boundaries but they don't have have the
boundaries why is that well the reason
why we don't have good boundaries is
because none of us were trained how to
set them I mean I want you to think
about your childhood for a minute your
childhood with your caregivers your
parents your grandparents whoever it is
naturally an imbalance right like when
you come into this world you are born
into a particular family you're born
into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion and based on
where you were born and to whom you were
born into in terms of the family
structure there were all kinds of rules
that you had to follow and if you did
not follow those rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine if you as like an eight-year-old
started to try to express boundaries
literally like mom cooks a uh you know a
pot pot roast dinner and you cross your
arms you're like you know Mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom would probably go guess
what youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
Crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so saying boundaries
when you're little doesn't really work
for the adults in your life and that's
why you never learned how to do it and
by the way your parents were probably
never taught how to have boundaries
either and so
I want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin where do you
even begin when it comes to learning how
to set healthy boundaries okay so first
things first where you're going to begin
is you're going to start to think about
boundaries in a completely new way okay
the number one mistake that we all make
I made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's Behavior that is the exact
opposite of how you should be thinking
about boundaries okay I didn't realize
this this is why I was lousy at setting
boundaries because I thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no no so how do I want you
to think about boundaries okay
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior and I'm gonna
take this a little bit further now
what I'm actually talking about is I'm
going to help you identify situations
people
um any kind of experience you might find
yourself in
where your boundary defines what you're
going to do in reaction to something
that's going on around you okay because
I think what I'm seeing a lot of online
are two things
it's this sort of quick Instagram advice
where it's like you've crossed a
boundary you're a toxic person you're no
longer in my life when the truth is the
behavior that we really need to be
policing is our own the opportunity for
growth and the way the boundaries can
support you is in looking at what you
need to change when it comes to certain
people certain situations or certain
choices and habits that you have okay
and we're gonna unpack this don't worry
but I really want to kind of land here
because if you start to turn the focus
back on yourself you're going to have a
much easier time with
applying the five rules around
boundaries that I'm about to teach you
okay so rule number one
always focus on yourself
what you will and what you won't allow
okay always focus on yourself what you
will and won't allow do not try to
control other people because you can't
okay think about boundaries as guard
rails that you set for yourself and I'm
going to give you a quick example we all
have that relative that loves to hear
them talk about politics right like it's
super annoying they're constantly going
on and on about politics okay and you
want this relative of yours to stop
talking about politics around you okay
what if I told you that expressing a
boundary with a relative telling them to
stop talking about politics around you
will probably only increase the
likelihood that they're going to
and so the better way to think about
boundaries is not
what do I need to say to Uncle Joe so
that Uncle Joe does not talk about
politics around me
that's not how you do this you don't go
Uncle Joe you're crossing a line with me
you're crossing a boundary I need you to
stop talking about politics
let's just role play that for a minute
how do you think that's going to work
that ain't gonna work very well is it no
because then Uncle Joe's going to flare
up and then you're gonna flare up and
now instead of having a boundary that
you held you've got a gigantic mess
that's been made instead you got to
think about that boundary with you okay
what are you going to do
and there are two examples of this you
could decide
that if that relative starts sounding
off about politics
that is a boundary for you and you will
remove yourself from the room
that's an example of how you can set a
boundary
another example is you could say
something to Uncle Joe and you could say
hey Uncle Joe
I love you
and I'd love to have you over for dinner
but if you plan on talking about
politics when we're together
We're not gonna have dinner
you have defined what you will tolerate
and not you didn't say do not talk about
politics you said I love you if we're
gonna have dinner together I'd love to
have you over for dinner
but not if we're talking politics
you've given Uncle Joe the option to
talk politics or not you've just made it
clear where you stand which is we're not
having dinner together if you opt to do
that do you see how that's about your
behavior
you've made it clear what you're gonna
do but Uncle Joe now has a choice to
either respect the boundary or not
fulfillment
is when you're satisfied
because you are fully developing
your deepest desires
and your character
fulfillment's very different than
happiness everybody
happiness comes and goes happiness is
fleeting happiness is like the waves
in an ocean or the waves on Lake
Michigan the Great Lakes here in the
United States which is where I grew up
on like Michigan
the waves they come and they go right
that's happiness it comes and it goes it
rauls in and out of your life and
oftentimes it feels like it's out of
your control
fulfillment is the ocean or the Great
Lakes itself
fulfillment is something way deeper
and fulfillment is about integrity
and meaning
and the fact that when you have
integrity and meaning in your life you
are fulfilled
you are satisfied because you are
fulfilling and fully developing your
deepest desires
and your character
and this is important and I'm gonna
really Hammer these words around meaning
and more importantly integrity
if I had to pick one word that was
important when it comes to you deepening
your level of fulfillment with your
whole life
the word is integrity
now this was brand new to me
you know I always thought about
fulfillment like oh find your joy find
your passion find your purpose like then
you'll be fulfilled
do things that you love you'll be
fulfilled it actually has more to do
with integrity
which is really cool and you know when I
explain why Integrity is so important
it's also going to illuminate all the
places in your life where you're not
fulfilled because I guarantee you
the places in your life where you're
missing fulfillment are also lacking
personal integrity
you're not operating
consistently with what you care about
you're not operating with Integrity in
terms of your values you're not spending
your time your energy and your resources
on what truly aligns with you from an
Integrity standpoint and so that's why
we're going to continue to hammer this
word integrity okay and that's great
because when you start to think about
cultivating personal integrity and how
that translates to more fulfillment in
your life it's going to make that
fulfillment something that you can
control it's going to make it deeply
personal it's going to make it something
that you can move the needle on it puts
the locus of control within your reach
let me talk about the two mistakes that
everybody makes okay when it comes to
fulfillment and this is why fulfillment
in some areas of your life
are Out Of Reach right now number one
the number one mistake that we make if
you're struggling with fulfillment in
any area of your life is that you're not
living according to your own values
you know I think we've all gone through
those periods of Our Lives where we are
drinking too much or we're spending too
much money or we're hanging out with the
wrong people or we're making unhealthy
choices and you know deep down inside
that this is not what you want to be
doing it's not what you should be doing
but because you are not living based on
your own values you don't respect
yourself
there's no way you're going to live a
fulfilled life if at the base level you
don't respect the choices that you're
making so can you identify an area of
your life right now either in the chat
or in the journal uh function in the app
an area of your life where you are not
living according to your own values I
see Health coming up for people I'm sure
if you think about how you're spending
your money or whether or not you're
saving money you're not aligned with
your values maybe you're doing work I
see productivity I see exercise so if
you're not living according to your own
values this is one reason why you're not
going to be fulfilled in your life
the second thing is that you spend your
time and your resources on things that
actually don't matter to you
you're spending your time and your
resources on things that don't matter to
you at the deepest level
these are the two big mistakes that we
all make and the good news here is that
these are mistakes that you can easily
identify that you can address and when
you do you take control back and you
will amp up the level of fulfillment
that you feel I'm going to say this
again
fulfillment is not the same thing as
happiness
fulfillment is meaning and integrity
and that's why habit number one and
building a foundation is about values
because you will only find fulfillment
true lasting deep fulfillment everybody
if you are following your values like a
compass
not your mood
you gotta follow your values and let
that be your compass that's how you
build the proper Foundation
and so what does that mean what does
that mean everybody well it means you
got to figure out what matters to you
okay and then you must develop the
simple discipline
to spend your time and energy on things
people experiences that align with what
matters to you
living with Integrity to what matters to
you is the secret of fulfillment
and I think you know I've alluded to
this earlier but you know I can think
about times in my life when either what
I was doing for work
or what I was doing with my free time
did not align with my values I haven't
lost anybody
that I love
so I would not say what I'm about to say
if somebody that I loved had died in
this pandemic
but I have found the great pause
that the last two months have forced me
to take to be the greatest gift
that I have received in the last decade
my kids have been home
I have been off the road I have been
forced to slow down
I have been reminded of what actually
matters your health your family your
friends
what you're doing to take care of your
mind and your body and your spirit
and making sure that you do something
with the time that you have that you
really really enjoy and the other thing
that it's really made me stop and think
about is making sure that I'm having fun
that my whole life isn't just work
and it's made me really start to think
about the fact that I don't want to go
back to the life that I was living
before the pandemic hit
how many of you feel that way
that this has been
a gigantic mental perspective
switch reset button that has boom hit
you really hard when you wake up
generally what the research shows is
that your brain is primed to be able to
focus
for the first four hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us
the time of day when your brain has the
most fuel and when your speed of
processing is awesome and when you are
able to direct your attention at what
you need to be focused on okay so now
there's a caveat to this
you can manufacture boosts of
productivity and boosts of feeling like
you've got a little bit more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so if you have a burst of
cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of the
research says but if you have a burst of
cardio you will get a little bit of
increase in fuel another thing that
helps is getting outside getting outside
uh when you start to feel your energy
and your focus start to go to empty
getting outside is another way to give
yourself a boost of brain power but
generally speaking everybody
you need to start to marry mornings with
Peak productivity if you can own your
mornings if you can put that thing that
matters to you first thing in the
morning and make a little bit of
progress on it
you are going to start to feel like you
are more in control you're going to
start to see yourself using your best
brain power and your highest level of
fuel at the thing that matters most to
you give yourself permission
to dream with the lid off this is really
important and the reason why this is
important is because I guarantee you
that right now you are not even allowing
yourself to fully dream or think about
or set goals that are truly aligned with
what you deeply want in your heart that
you aren't even able to manifest
properly because you're not even honest
with yourself about what you actually
want this is a really common thing
because you're allowing your self-doubt
you are allowing your fears your anxiety
your insecurity you're allowing where
you are to dictate and limit where you
want to go and so step one super
important you must allow yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system I write about the RAS
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit the
RAS is a filter in your mind and you can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do in
order to teach yourself how to dream
with the lid off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliberate action and you write
down what you want you are signaling to
your brain that you deserve to have
these things you're signaling to your
brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off so that's step number one you're
going to start writing down five things
that you want every single morning as a
way to train your mind to let you dream
freely the reason why visualization and
picturing yourself succeeding and
allowing yourself to feel the happiness
and the pride that comes with picturing
a positive future the reason why that's
as important is let's say Shelley does
that every single day this week every
day she wakes up she walks for five
minutes and as she's walking on that
treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10K in six months and how
proud she is every time she does that
she is changing what's going on up here
this isn't something I made up this is
true and it's not only true based on
science but let's think about this from
a common sense perspective if Shelley
wakes up or if you wake up every single
morning and instead of thinking about
the worst case instead of looking at
your body in the mirror and going I'm so
fat I'm so out of shape I'll never run a
10K this is never going to happen why
didn't I exercise last year I hate my
flabby stomach I hate my my big thighs I
hate how out of share I'm embarrassed
like if that's what you're thinking
then that is what you're allowing your
brain to continue to filter the world
through
if you start teaching yourself the skill
of visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K
if after an entire week what Shelley
does is she looks in the mirror and she
goes I'm getting stronger every day I'm
really proud of myself even though I'm
I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying you're
flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10K
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just seven to
ten days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm gonna say I'm proud I'm doing
this why do you sign up
it's going to filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why I'm so glad you're doing it when I
hear the word productivity
I don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list
because part of the reason why you don't
feel productive is because you're busy
doing the things that aren't important
to you yeah do you need to make sure you
have milk or you got almond milk or oat
milk in the fridge of course you do but
have you ever notice that all the busy
crap in life uh tends to take care of
itself that you don't really need to
focus your time and energy on the
minutia that's on your to-do list
because that stuff tends to grab your
attention what you really need to do is
figure out how to create time and how to
create the focus that you need in order
to feel like you are making progress on
the important things
and that's really what productivity
means to me you get all kinds of stuff
done you're really busy in your life
aren't you but are you getting progress
made on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan you need to have a very
short list every week of what actually
matters to you okay because I guarantee
you if you were to do an audit of the
way that you spend your time this week
you would probably see that 95 of your
time is spin on things that you really
don't care about
and even more scary I bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
TV on also answering emails that is the
least productive way to spend your time
multitasking spending your time just
sort of zoning out on things that don't
matter what I want you to do is I want
you right now to think about what is it
between now and the end of this week for
example what is it that matters to you
what's the most important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay it's a whole other conversation for
us to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you what
you do not have right now is you do not
have a plan for
prioritizing the important stuff in your
life if you struggle with boundaries I
want you to know you're not alone and
this is super common and
um one of the reasons why I'm excited to
share everything that I've learned about
boundaries with you is because I used to
be the kind of person that had zero
boundaries I mean not a nothing zilch
nothing in fact there were periods of my
life where it was worse than zero
because I was so attached in romantic
relationships that I literally would be
become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally if it's possible to have
negative boundaries meaning you like
somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as uh emotionally
attached in relationships and is people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify
communicate and uphold boundaries in my
life you can learn how to do this too
okay and so that's what we're going to
unpack in this video
so I think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why we don't have good
boundaries is because none of us were
trained how to set them I mean I want
you to think about your childhood for a
minute your childhood with your
caregivers your parents your
grandparents whoever it is naturally an
imbalance right like when you come into
this world you are born into a
particular family you're born into a
particular culture religion economic
situation a place in the world a race
like a religion and based on where you
were born and to whom you were born into
in terms of the family structure there
were all kinds of rules that you had to
follow and if you did not follow those
rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine if you as like an eight-year-old
started to try to express boundaries
literally like mom cooks a uh you know a
pot pot roast dinner and you cross your
arms you're like you know Mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom would probably go guess
what youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
Crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for
work and that's why you never learned
how to do it and by the way your parents
were probably never taught how to have
boundaries either and so
I want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin where do you
even begin when it comes to learning how
to set healthy boundaries okay so first
things first where you're going to begin
is you're going to start to think about
boundaries in a completely new way okay
the number one mistake that we all make
I made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's behavior that is the exact
opposite of how you should be thinking
about boundaries okay and I'm going to
give you a bunch of examples don't worry
I didn't realize this this is why I was
lousy at setting boundaries because I
thought that my boundaries control what
other people do no no no no no no so how
do I want you to think about boundaries
okay
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
yep I'm going to say that again
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior understand that
you can find people to support you you
will always find people to criticize you
watch though how when somebody outside
of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking that gets triggered that
disempowers you
that I won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath I won't have the
words
yeah they won't be the right words and I
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not smart enough to make
a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that I'm stupid they're okay there we go
that's a good one not a good one but you
know what I mean that good one because
okay I'm a piece of [__]
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
I don't know who told me that when did
you start believing that
it's a little girl yeah
God I've just been saying it for so long
I I don't know that's okay she said I've
been saying it for so long I don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're going to start to connect the
dots okay and so here's the thing at
some point you started telling yourself
whatever I'm a piece as a strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well I'm a piece of [__] you actually
got really quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations when
you would have been abused or something
it worked because it protected you as
weird as it sounds yeah is that but are
you seeing something what are you seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah we couldn't make noise and okay and
if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah I didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so every time that you are
in a situation where you need to speak
up how many are you relating to this by
the way
I have a theory about all of us
that we have patterns and strategies
that we would we created when we were
little
in order to survive situations
and what she
internalized was don't speak up
and you're a piece of [__] you do
and believe me that protected your ass
it worked because you didn't speak up
and you didn't get in trouble with your
dad right and I still got the love so if
I speak up now I'm going to lose my
dad's love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got written
when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked the problem is now
that you're working now it's not working
now it's not working now not working now
and see exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on a stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up
Europe yes freeze and you're gonna go
five four three two one the only thing
to that actually overrides this pattern
is to speak
and through speaking
you will see that you're not a piece of
[__]
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
I guess I'm just a piece of something to
say
yes
that's right and I also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff even the heavy stuff because
it loses its grip on me it works for me
it may not work for you
but it's something to try first of all
you got to give yourself permission to
really have what you want okay because
you got to have the thing that you're
visualizing be something that is
authentically something that you want
number two you must see yourself taking
the steps the tiny actions and doing the
work that will lead you to creating or
having what you want
third you gotta feel in your body what
it feels like to do the work and you
also have to feel Pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really imprinting and training and
preparing for it and fourth uh obviously
you got to take the actions and all of
that manifesting and preparing inspires
you to take the actions but one place
where so many folks get stuck when they
start trying to make manifesting a daily
habit is you go and you know what you
want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you I'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend Mel Robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire and the
power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now I'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the Harvard Business
School review they did eight different
studies at the University of Wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay I want you to imagine
yourself asking for a raise or applying
for that dream job when you visualize
yourself doing it you immediately focus
in on minutia you start imagining all
kinds of things that could go wrong you
start arguing against yourself and doubt
comes flooding in you have a very
cautious mindset when you place yourself
in those scenarios however if you were
to visualize me Mel Robbins asking for
that race immediately your mindset
switches to being very bold being
creative seeing all kinds of
opportunities and in fact when you not
only visualize me your friend Mel
Robbins asking for that raise that you
want when you give me advice you're
super enthusiastic you're like Mel you
should go for it and I bet in your life
you have probably told friends or loved
ones you should ask for more money and
you mean it because you're visualizing
them but you yourself won't visualize
yourself doing that you talk yourself
out of it we've all had this experience
you yourself are probably sitting there
by your right Mel I constantly tell my
friends you deserve more you should
break up with that jerk you should go
for it but when it comes to yourself
you see the excuses in that so I want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend Mel Robbins or insert
anybody that you love part of the reason
why you don't feel productive is because
you're trying to complete everything and
so let's take one of the things that I
saw somebody write that you want to uh
clean up one of the spare rooms in your
apartment or in your house that maybe
there's a spare bedroom and you have
been wanting to turn it into a home
office or maybe one of the kids has
moved out of the house and you want to
declutter that room like in a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me our daughter moved out
and started her life uh you know post
college and our other daughter is out in
Los Angeles going to college and we no
joke
have three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it and it has been sitting
there for two months so maybe you have a
pile of that kind of stuff in your house
this is not a priority for me I'm
perfectly fine with it sitting in the
room where our laundry is the priority
for me this week is to carve out
dedicated time to hang out with our 16
year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage that could take
you two days to do it the right way
right because you know if you don't give
yourself enough time then you're gonna
piles and so then you think I can't get
it done and so then you never schedule
it right okay we're not going to worry
about completion everybody we're going
to worry about progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress it can shrink the amount of
time that you need maybe all that you're
going to do is you're going to work on
one dresser in the room or you're going
to work on one shelving unit in the
garage and by simply making the time to
number one identify what matters to you
and number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will Define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about
um what you need to do okay I literally
have notes for this oh there we go and I
just lost it because I really want to
make sure that I teach you all this
stuff so
um here Becca can you help me because
this is not oh because my thing is not
never mind guys I am I am trying
multitasking is not how you be
productive and you're watching me
multitask right now
we're gonna get into some of the science
now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that I first learned
about in the Harvard Business Review so
if it's in the Harvard Business Review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from Harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
uh comes from a study where researchers
looked at I believe it was 14 000 work
journals and what they found after
looking at the work journals of how
people spent their time fourteen
thousand people is that at the end of
the week the people that felt like they
had been the most productive and the
people who felt the most fulfilled by
their work week were the people who
simply made progress on something that
mattered and so by you identifying what
matters to you this week and by you
identifying a way that you can make a
small amount of progress on it you are
leveraging This research research from
Harvard Business review of about what
creates productivity and meaning and
fulfillment in your life and that's
making progress on something that
matters you need to do the work okay you
got to do the work because it's only
through your actions that you will
accomplish what you want let's say uh
that you've always wanted to climb a
particular Mountain okay there's a
mountain called Haystack it's not even
that tall so I should probably pick a
bigger one but let's just call it
Haystack Mountain you've always wanted
to climb Haystack Mountain you pull up
to Haystack Mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know National Forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my God
that's a really far away you know I
don't really know how I feel about doing
this anymore because that looks like
it's going to take a really long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go I don't think I want to
do this because I don't think I feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamed of
climbing you've now come up with an
excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it you pull the rip cord you're out
of there in order to have what you want
in life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down and look
at the first step in front of you and
then you must take the action and start
walking toward what you want and it'll
be a hell of a lot easier for you to do
that if you have also been putting in
the time every day consistently to not
only see yourself walking up that trail
step by step but that you have felt
yourself pushing through the resistance
the fear the obstacles the excuses that
are stopping you now and feel proud in
every fiber of your being as you push
through those obstacles and see yourself
and feel yourself doing the work that's
how you manifest properly and if you do
that before you pull into the National
Park parking lot if you look up but that
mountain and you see clouds and it
starts raining it won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment and your mind body and spirit and
you my friend will start walking up that
trail
and you're going to be proud
do not let the fact that you have spent
a certain amount of time or you're a
certain age or you're too early or
you're too late or all of that crap to
invalidate the truth the truth is you're
right on time
if you're having the wake-up call that I
intend for you to have as you listen to
this as you're realizing that your
dreams are as alive as they have ever
been
if you are starting to go oh my god I've
been against myself
I'm going to before myself
if you're starting to say wow I really
have put the lid on I really have
stopped allowing myself for giving
myself permission to have something
incredible happen in my life
if you're having the wake-up call that I
intended good now let me tell you
something else there is no deadline on
your dreams and there is no age at which
you're supposed to do this
you can start a business at 18. you can
quit the job you had out of college at
24. you can go back to technical school
after getting a master's at 31. you can
literally adopt a child at the age of 39
when you're single you can go to nursing
school after you've raised your kids and
you're 42 years old you can learn how to
teach your first online course at the
age of 48 you could become a podcast
host at the age of 54. you could get
married for the first time at 63. you
could Skydive at 71. you could run your
first marathon at 82.
your dreams do not disappear
there is no age at when you can't do
something or when you're too early it's
complete [__] your dreams are
something you were born with they are
your responsibility and they are also
the life force inside of you so stop
running away from them and turn toward
them run toward your dreams stop arguing
against them and be the loudest voice
for them and for crying out loud stop
extinguishing
that flame that's burning inside you
enough with the excuses enough with the
jokes and the downplaying enough
with this fear
your job
is to turn toward that flame
turn toward that flame and freaking fan
it
fan it
with all your might
that flame inside you is supposed to
burn bright
and the only way that that's going to
happen is when you are honest with
yourself about that thing you've been
denying about that calling that you feel
about the fact that you're meant for
more than where you're at right now that
you deserve to be happy that those
dreams are real and you have within you
the ability to chip away at them and
that when you wake up every single day
and you write down those five dreams
and you see and you hear and you feel
the fact that your life
has Clues your life is trying to help
you
your life is trying to help you become
who you're destined to become
I want you to know something
you're going to wake up happier every
day
you're going to wake up feeling more
alive and more self-expressed and more
connected and energized when you wake up
for your dreams
so many of us have this perfectionism
Gene and the reason why we're
perfectionists is we're trying to
insulate ourselves from criticism that
if you get it perfect no one will give
you feedback if you get it right
nobody's going to criticize you if you
do it perfect then no one will be able
to attack you and the problem with that
and that's just another side of the same
coin which is the fear of disappointing
people you're managing not disappointing
people not by lying and not by being
codependent but by actually trying to be
a perfectionist so that nobody
criticizes you so let me tell you a
story about the fear of disappointing
people in my own life because this is
the biggest trigger in my life I mean it
goes back to being in fourth grade right
it's there and this is another thing I I
literally have to remind myself of this
everybody every single day you cannot
remove the things that trigger you you
can't if you've been doing a pattern
since fourth grade there will be things
for the rest of your life that will
trigger that pattern to come up but you
can always choose not to repeat the
pattern so you'll be triggered and be
afraid that you're going to disappoint
somebody that's real that's normal it's
natural it's part of being a human being
I think it's interwoven into every
relationship where you love somebody but
you don't have to behave the way that
you always behaved when you're nervous
about disappointing somebody so let me
give you a dumb story you ready when my
husband and I got married my father gave
us this really Incredible Gift he gave
us an antique pool table I grew up in
Muskegon Michigan where Brunswick was
founded and my dad has a hobby of going
to garage sales and estate sales and
buying old dilapidated pool tables and
then he restores them so when Chris and
I got married he bought us an old
dilapidated pool table from the same era
as our house which is the 1870s He
restored the whole thing and then
recently he and I rented a U-Haul and we
drove this sucker from Muskegon Michigan
to Boston Massachusetts choose it's my
dad and I took a road trip get there and
we assemble the pool table in what used
to be our playroom fast forward three or
four years the speaking business takes
off my business starts to grow we have
people that work for us and my kids are
older we don't need a playroom we need
an office the pool table is in the
middle of this thing for the first two
years of having the office we kept the
pool table there why because I didn't
want my dad to be disappointed because I
love him now he visits our house twice a
year for two or three days with my mom
and I kept this thing occupying a third
of our office for two years and then I
realized I'm being ridiculous I'm being
absolutely ridiculous now here's the
thing will he be disappointed if I take
the pool table down absolutely
definitely there are always going to be
things that you do decisions that you
have to make in your life in your
business for your family that will
disappoint other people it's unavoidable
but the fact that he's going to be
disappointed should never be the reason
that I don't do something that is
aligned with my values now let's take it
a step further when you make a decision
that is likely going to disappoint
people or that does still make the
decision because it's your life there's
nothing worse than when you start to Rob
your future and your life and your
happiness because you're so focused on
other people however if you love people
you can still take care of them when you
make that decision so let me go back to
the example of the pool table so I knew
I was going to take it down I knew my
father was going to be disappointed I
was disappointed I don't have a big
house so I don't you know I don't have
the room for a huge pool table I don't
have a finished basement like a lot of
people I don't have like a cool garage
game room thing like I just don't have
it I called him first and said I need to
talk to you about something you know the
pool table I love the pool table dad my
business is growing so much I actually
need an office and oh great it'll be
great in the office and I'm like well
yeah would except I have you know three
or four people showing up we got to put
some desks in there for now even went
down well you could put a piece of
plywood and they could work on the pool
table and then they could do the thing
and then the thing and now my heart is
racing because I don't want to
disappoint my dad and now he's fighting
for the and I had to just say for me dad
hears what's going to happen I'm going
to hire professional movers in the pool
table business to disassemble this with
love and care we're going to store it
beautifully when I either get a
full-time office off-site or I build a
barn or I build a different house this
will have its own beautiful room
dedicated to you so we had this
beautiful conversation now was he
disappointed absolutely when they come
to the house and visit which they just
did and they walk into the office do I
feel a Pang you better believe I do it
doesn't matter that's all normal I still
need to make the decisions that I need
to make and the difference what's
changed is how I relate to that fear so
instead of what I would do in the past
is I would make a decision that doesn't
serve me I'd leave the pool table and
then I'd be all about it I'd leave the
pool table as a way to make my dad happy
but it makes me miserable to leave it
there because I need the space right and
then I'd be kind of annoyed and then
he'd come and I'd fake play pool because
I kind of want to run you know you know
what I'm saying like we do all this
that's not real and what I've been able
to do for myself in some instances when
I catch it is to hit it head on and to
be authentic and to still take care of
people and what I've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you you know
you're never going to get around this
everybody in your family is going to be
disappointed with you probably once a
day probably and you have the ability to
retrain how you respond to that trigger
that rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is make the
decision that's aligned with your values
and the thing that supports you and then
take care of the person by being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody the way we've all been handling
it myself included is manipulation lying
resentment withholding and that doesn't
serve anybody the things that you need
to
in order to to increase
Wellness
confidence
purpose a sense of control when it comes
to day-to-day habits in your home life
or at work
are really boring on their face
and so
I am coming out of the gates to say that
because the more successful I Have
Become
the happier I Have Become
the more boring my life looks on paper
I'm not kidding the things I'm about to
share with you are not sexy
they are not exciting
but they are the foundation
for everything that you want and that
you deserve in your life so we're going
to talk first okay when it comes to
Wellness
about something that you may not think a
lot about
because when you're building a business
when you're going for your dreams when
you are pursuing a big passionate life
you think about all the stuff that
you're doing right
one of the most important things when it
comes to Wellness strategies for home
and for work is sleep
period
the more successful that I've become the
you know the more boring my life looks
and the more sleep that I get
my husband and I are in bed by 9 30 on
most nights and the reason why is
because I know the science around sleep
now it's kind of boring to to tell it to
you so I'm going to just give you some
of the highlights
it is impossible for your brain for your
body and for your spirit to do what it's
been designed to do if you have not
given it the rest that it deserves
the research on this is just something
you can't argue with
it is so horrible for your brain when
you do not get a good night's sleep
the research shows that not only does it
impact your mood but when you do not
have enough sleep let's talk with uh you
know an all-nighter if you've ever
pulled an all-nighter I used to be the
queen of the all-nighters in college and
in law school
when you pull an all-nighter the
all-nighters impact on your brain is the
equivalent to head trauma it actually
shrinks your prefrontal cortex the part
of the brain that you need in order to
be able to focus in order to be able to
learn new behavior and so sleep is
essential if you want to be successful
you must prioritize your sleep if you
want a sense of wellness and in health
you must prioritize your sleep
I I read this study once that if you've
got three days in a row where you get
less than six hours of sleep at night
it is the equivalent
of being legally drunk when it comes to
your speed of processing your ability to
focus and so one of these foundational
principles when it comes to your success
and your Wellness both at home and at
work is you making sleep a serious
priority so what are some tactical
takeaways you know I'm going to steal
something from Brandon that he posted
that you may have seen on his uh his
Instagram page because it is an
excellent summary of what we call a wind
down routine morning routines right now
are all the rage how many of you have a
morning routine right you rely on your
morning routine how you set your day up
is how the day ends up but your morning
routine doesn't begin in the morning
everybody
it begins the night before
it begins with you going to bed at a
reasonable hour and it begins with you
completing your day and winding your day
down in a way that sets you up for
Success Brendan posted this post that I
just love that he called the three two
one formula three hours before bed you
stop eating two hours before bed you
stop working one hour before bed no more
screens and you want to know why
anything that's on a screen is somebody
else's dream
your dreams deserve a great night's
sleep
your dreams deserve your focus and
attention
and so I want you to be mindful about
how you wind down your day the three two
one principle from Brendan we're
stealing it here one hour beforehand
you're gonna turn off your screens the
next thing that I want you to do is
absolutely no phone in the bedroom
you're going to hear me talk about this
incessantly and the reason why is you're
addicted to it this does not belong in
your bedroom okay
and the reason why I don't want it in
the bedroom is because I want you to
have a good night's sleep and this this
is in Arms Reach you're gonna lay in bed
and look at it and that's going to
interrupt your ability to sleep in
addition the blue light for this uh on
the phone even when you're asleep it
interrupts your ability to drift into
the deeper REM sleep and you want to
know the the actual purpose of sleep
everybody it has to do with with Focus
this is so fascinating when you
understand it of course we know that you
need rest right of course we know that
you've got to put yourself to bed so
that your body can rest you need it but
do you know the real reason
why your brain needs you to sleep
I'm going to tell you
when you're asleep
half of your brain
can turn off and go into an autopilot
mode
and the other half of your brain
gets to go to work doing something
critically important for your success
while this part of the brain is on
autopilot and asleep
this part of the brain takes your
experience from today
and starts filing away
all of the things that happened to you
today all the memories all of the
lessons all of the skill building
absolutely everything that happened you
day gets filed away like books returning
to a library system
if you didn't sleep you wouldn't have
any memories
and so it's critically important
for your ability to focus
for your ability to build knowledge for
your ability to become stronger and more
resilient
for your ability to be productive for
you to sleep so that you can take
everything that happened today and while
you're busy sleeping you can store it
away as knowledge that you're building
on because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to see my one-on-one interview
with Mel check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I hope you lose Evan I hope your
business goes bankrupt Evan Evan you're
a terrible person I spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way